(laughing)
- You know how crazy (indistinct)
in some States in America,
if you get caught drink
driving, they put a thing
on your car to blow into it every time.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Some guy like he'd made a video,
he was like, how do we avoid doing that?
By inhaling gold cola instead.
(laughing)
- That sounds safe.
- All the cards were like,
I feel like you're missing the point
of why this is in your car,
(laughing) but anyway...
- You get like in Ava, right?
They just just made like an
alcoholic version of like LCL,
(laughing) so you just
like.(laughing hysterically)
Hey guys and welcome to another episode
of Trash Tastes Podcast,
where we talk about our
trash tastes, anime,
gaming whatever, I don't know.
Actually, we've never talked about gaming.
I dunno, whatever we have our
trash tastes and everything.
I am your host for today, Gigguk.
And with me is Connor, CDawgVA ,
and Joey, The Anime Man.
(indistinct) Keeping it real today.
(laughing)
- Okay, you sure?
Okay I cut you off with that.
- No facetious nicknames.
- What did you wanna say
Connor, what did you wanna say?
- I mean if you mentioned it,
should we just talk about games then?
Like what games you've been playing
or what have you played or something?
- Have you been playing anime games?
- No, I never play anime games.
- Do you never?
- I never play anime games.(mumbling)
- Okay, okay what
constitutes as an anime game?
- That's the thing.
- If the characters go
(screaming) every ten seconds.
(Gigguk laughing)
- That's like every game.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You can say Last Of Us is an anime game.
(both chuckling)
- They have a cute (indistinct).
(screaming)
- I don't know, like how
many games do you guys play?
Because I found that,
I just have zero time to
play a lot of games nowadays.
- Now that the quarantine
is over here, right?
- Yeah.
- As a gamer.
(cross talk)
- As a pro gamer.
- I just wanted to say as a gamer.
I don't know, I'm kidding.
No, I mean, I feel like
it's probably the thing,
that got cut the most
when I became an adult.
Like out of everything that I do,
watching films doing anything else,
like, gaming got cut down the most to me.
Cause in university..
- Cause that's what you used to do, right?
- I used to do gaming
for like 12 hours a day.
No problem.
- Jesus.
- Yeah, it was easy.
I loved that shit.
(cross talk)
- Depends on the game actually, for me.
Like I played, when Person
Five first came out,
I definitely played like....
- Still haven't played Persona Five.
- More than 12 hours a day on that.
- I know like for me,
the reason I don't play many
games anymore is because,
when I get into a game, like get into.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like one of those
guys who just can't go,
like I either have eight
hour gaming sessions,
or I just don't game at all.
There's like no in between.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like especially if it's like an RPG
or a story-driven game,
like I remember when I
last played Persona Five,
it was just like, just block out my week,
nothing is happening this week,
but me was playing Persona Five.
Which is why I haven't played
Royal, yeah.(indistinct)
- Yeah, I mean I've played Persona Five,
Persona Five Royal and
Persona Five Scramble.
And I think in total that took maybe like
five, 600 hours out of my life.
- This man finds time,
where time shouldn't exist.
(Gigguk laughing)
- I mean, that's what I like
about animal crossing, right?
Because I'm still
playing that to this day,
and I've put in maybe like
three, 400 hours into that game.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- But that's the thing, right?
It's like unlike most gaming
sessions where it's like,
zero hours or eight hours.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Animal crossing is
just one of those games
we could play for half an
hour, and then you just draw.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- That's fair enough.
- Which is what I like, right?
It's just like a little thing,
to just kind of do on the sideline.
- As someone who plays league
of legends, I feel like,
even if it is a 40-minute game session.
- Pro gamer here.
- That shit felt Like eight hours.
The mental Battle that
it took to play a game
of league of legends took eight hours.
But I fucking used to love
playing league of legends man,
I was so addicted.
- Are there any like actual-like games,
based off animated that you guys like?
- What'd you mean?
- Like by anime games,
I don't mean like games with
animated looking characters.
Like I'm not talking
about like a Xenoblade
or like Dragon Quest 11 kind of..
- Has there ever been
a good anime spin off?
I'm sure there has,
it's just, I can't really
think of any right now.
(cross talk)
- I (indistinct) the Attack
on Titan game on steam,
I was like, yo, I'm so hype.
I get 10 minutes into the game like, huh!
(laughing)
- Probably Dragon Ball Fighters, that's..
- You like fighting games?
- I mean, I'm not really much
of a fighter game enthusiast,
but I mean, I had fun playing it,
and I think it was a pretty good game.
- I enjoyed, what was the
latest like Natto funny game?
Like I'm not a huge fan of Natto.
(crosstalk) (laughing)
Something like that, I don't know.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But like the latest
one on that on steam,
like I think someone gifted that to me
and then I just gave it a
go, but I was like, you know,
I'm not that much of an advocate
for like fighting games,
I'm not that good at fighting games.
And I'm not much of a fan
of the narrative franchise,
but I gave it a go.
That game's genuinely fun.
- [Gigguk] Right.
- I mean, you have, what's
the Pokemon fighting game?
- [Connor] Oh, Pokken?
I like Pokken, Pokken is good, I like..
- If you like Pokken, it's
similar to that just.(indistinct)
- No one ever wants to
play Pokken, and I'm like.
- Pokken is so fun.
- It's good though,
because I do, you know,
you bring your switch to a party, right?
You're like, I've got Mario party.
I've got Mario kart.
I've got all these amazing
multiplayer games, right?
- Yeah.
- The last thing anyone
wants to play is Pokken.
But if people give it a
chance, it's actually fun.
I don't think it's a great game,
but it's a really fun party game.
- It's fun, it's really really fun, yeah.
- It's just like a brain
dead fighting game.
It's really easy (indistinct) down a lot.
(Joey laughing)
But I think it needed to be,
cause I suck at fighting games.
- Oh, here's a question for you guys,
and have you ever watched an anime,
and thought this would
be a really cool game?
Cause I can think of one
off the top of my head.
- Sold on.
(Gigguk laughing)
I am joking (indistinct).
- Would (indistinct) be a good game bro?
- I've played the Solo
online games, they will suck.
(cross talk)
- Hey, wait there is one in Arcadia.
- Yeah, and I'm not just saying that
because I don't like solo online,
like genuinely, they all suck.
- I just had a huge epiphany.
- Yes.
- What?
- The Jojo Battle of The Jojo Fortnite.
- The Jojo Fortnite game.
- Yeah, in Japan they have an arcade game,
and it's a battle Royale of Jojo.
And you go on Mario,
and all you do is like,
try and fucking punch each
other to death, it's so fun.
- That game is fun.
- It's kind of bad,
it's kind of a bad game.
- It kinda sucks, but it's fun.
- It's good.
- It's fucking great, because like,
I completely forgot about
Japanese arcades as well,
and just..
- Oh my God, we haven't
even spoken about that.
- Yeah, we haven't spoken about that.
- My second home baby.
(Gigguk laughing)
I'm (indistinct) arcades,
I was at an arcade just
yesterday actually.
Cause I wanted to get a,
what's that piano game that
you and I are really into?
- It's like Nostalgia.
- Nostalgia?
I think it's called.
- I think it's something like that.
Basically, in Japanese,
Japanese arcades are fucking next level.
Like arcades just didn't die here.
And there's so many cool
things about Japanese arcades,
that you just can't get
anywhere else in the world.
- If you think American arcades are fun,
you will nut in a Japanese arcade.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- It's a different experience in arcade,
cause growing up my arcade
experience is always like,
you know, House Of The Dead, those types.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah.
- So like party games...
(crosstalk)
- Time crisis.
- Yeah, Time Crisis, right.
That's like, and they do have those.
I'd say those are the only games
that really translated well
from like Western arcades.
Like maybe that sense
of evolution as well.
- I dunno, cause like Japanese arcades,
have so many rhythm games.
- It's like 80% rhythm games.
- They've got so many unique
ideas about rhythm games.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Cause I remember when I was like,
before I came to a Japanese
arcade, I was like, Oh yeah,
rhythm games aren't
really my thing, you know.
I didn't really enjoy DDR
or that kind of stuff.
And then I went to a Japanese arcade,
and there are just so many
different types of rhythm games.
- Oh it's crazy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it's fucking crazy.
I mean, I thought you
know, playing guitar here
and just pretending to be a band,
or you're , what was it, rock band.
- Rock band, yeah.
- But you're playing
basically, every instrument.
I was like, rhythm games aren't
gonna get better than this,
cause you're pretending to
be playing the instruments.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And then Japanese arcades be like,
now how about we just invent instruments?
- Yeah, yeah.
You see this DJ board
right here, six buttons.
You're a DJ now.
(Gigguk laughing)
And It feels amazing when you
like turn the knobs and stuff.
And it's like ooh, ooh, okay.
I'm making some music right now, goddamn.
Yeah, but no I wasn't the exact same.
Like, I've always liked rhythm games,
even way before you
know, like rhythm heaven
and stuff like that on the DS,
like I played the fuck out
of those games, loved it.
But when I moved here, I
was the exact same, right?
I was like, I'm not a huge fan of DDR,
never really played a lot of rhythm games
like in Western arcades.
And I didn't really even
have an arcade in Australia.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- We didn't really have an
arcade that was nearby enough.
Like we had one in the city.
- Yeah, there was one that
was really far away from me.
- Yeah, but like the city for me,
where I live is like a 45 minute drive.
- Oh shoot.(indistinct)
- So to a 14 year old,
it might as well be in
a different country.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So my only experience with arcades,
is the Japanese arcades.
- Yeah.
- But even when I was little,
I would go to a Japanese arcade,
and I never really
touched the rhythm games,
because all these like high
school kids are around it.
As a 10 year old, you don't
want to go into that crowd.
(crosstalk)
- It's intuitive,
those dudes on some of
these games are insane.
- Yeah.
- You know, someone is like insane,
when there's like a 16 year old,
just rocking up in front
of a (indistinct) machine,
and he just puts his gloves on.
(Gigguk laughing)
- Get the gloves.
If they wear gloves, they're like serious.
- It's like the anime moment, you know?
When they put on the glove, it's like..
- He puts on the gloves,
he just does the shine,
and he just gets ready, like
he just stretches himself.
- Is that the game
where they go like this?
- Yeah, it's like..
- Yeah, they for some reason,
I don't know why all
the good players do it.
There must be a trick there,
but they all throw their hands in the air,
when they are playing this piano.
- Like they just don't care?
- That's an actual movement.
(laughing hysterically)
- What?
- Wait what?
- What did you say?
- Don't worry about it.(laughing)
- I'm gonna see the replay
anyway, you mother(indistinct).
- No but like I played (indistinct) once,
because I was also (crosstalk).
- That's an actual movement
you need to do you have to,
there's a sensor in the actual board,
that senses your hands moving up.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But a lot of them do
it like when they've,
you know in the movies or they
finished their piano solo,
and they just like raise their hand?
- Yeah.
- They go high, no fucking around.
- It looks like, you
know, a classical pianist,
just finishing their performance, right?
- But they are doing it every two seconds.
(crosstalk)
- I mean like, they're almost
putting in as many inputs
as like a Japanese pianist,
like a professional pianist sometimes.
It looks so cool though,
when someone's good,
you're like, man this is amazing.
This is like a spectator sport right here.
- Yeah, But then you think about man,
how many 100 yen coins did
they have to go through.
- Oh yeah.
- To get to that level?
- (indistinct) You get like
three songs most of the time.
So about 10 minutes for
about a hundred yen,
which is less than a dollar.
- So wait, so what are
the go-to rhythm games
for you guys at an arcade?
- I like the one you showed me.
I can't remember what it was called,
but it's the one where
it's like a massive circle.
- Oh yeah, Waka.
- Waka, yeah, yeah.
And basically it's a really unique input,
where it's like the entire circle,
and you have to like follow the lines
and everything like that.
- [Connor] We have a video on screen.
- [Joey] Yeah, I'm sure.
- [Gigguk] It was something that,
it's really games like
this, that you just can't,
that I've just never seen before.
- Yeah.
- That shit burned my fingers though.
When you're trying to do that (screaming).
- It was the first time I
(indistinct) and I was like,
should I buy gloves?
(laughing)
- It's like a plastic thing, right?
And some of the inputs are
like do a full three 60
with your hands.
So you're just sliding your sweaty palms
all around this thing.
And you're like, ah, trying
to get your hand around.
- I was like, oh that's where
the gloves come in handy.
I understand.
- Cause the thing is,
they're no buttons as well.
They're all just sensors.
So you're just here like, smashing this,
smashing this hard surface like, dude.
And it just hurts your fingers.
- It hurts.
- Oh my God.
- It really fucking hurts.
- Shit hurts.
I love the, like the
piano one but that's cause
it's basically, what's the
other piano one where the guys
do the thing in the air?
What's it called?
- Uh tune(indistinct).
- I feel like that's the hard version.
And the one that I likes is the easy one,
because it's like a piano thing,
but, you don't have to
actually hit the right,
just close enough.
- Just close somewhere around there.
- So you basically look at the screen,
and you just do the, it's
really like beginner friendly.
- Yeah.
- And I really like it
because a lot of them,
like there's, I feel the problem
with a lot of the games is,
there's medium and then
there's fucking insane.
Like there's no in-between.
And I always had this
problem with guitar hero,
where like I could do medium fine.
But when we put the little pinky involved,
that's when it all fell
apart, like I couldn't do it.
- It makes you feel like a pianist.
(laughing)
- Oh my God, shut the fuck up.
Or the classic, the Taiko drums, right?
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, that's genius
- [Connor] That's like,
whenever you bring someone,
you are like, get (indistinct)
- [Joey] Yeah come on, you all enjoy this.
- It's so easy to understand, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like monkey brain
mode activated.(laughing)
- I hit two places.
Okay, I understand.
- Yeah.
- What about you?
- I mean, the one I always
go to is Groove Coaster.
- Oh you always play Groove
Coaster, It looks cool though.
- Groove Coaster is fun.
- Which one's that one?
- Groove Coaster is the
one with the giant screen.
- It's like(indistinct) in HD.
- [Gigguk] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And there's two like knobs,
that you have to like move around and tap.
And I sucked at it at first,
but then I went to this
con in Washington DC,
like two years ago, maybe three years ago.
- [Gigguk] Right.
And they had a Groove Coaster machine,
but no one was in front of it.
And at this point I'd never
played Groove Coaster before.
- Yeah.
- And I just saw this
Groove Coaster machine
that nobody was lining up in front of.
- Yeah.
- And it was free to play.
- Yeah.(crosstalk)
- So I was like, I got like
two hours to kill, fuck it.
And no one's lining up
in front of this thing.
Let's do it.
And I got so good in those
two hours where I was like.
I have to come back to Japan and like,
actually get on these machines
and then ever since then,
I've loved it.
And there's also , what's the other one,
what's the cube one?
I keep forgetting.
- [Connor] Oh the one that you go like,
tap the things in time?
- [Joey] Yeah tap the things in time.
- [Connor] I forgot what that's called.
- [Joey] That was really old.
- [Connor] That's everywhere.
- [Joey] That's like a classic one game
in the Japanese arcades.
- Cause I remember my
first experience with
like Japanese arcade games.
There's always that fear,
where you're just like,
I have no idea what I'm doing.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
Like especially at conventions
when there's always that guy.
That guy who just like,
and he's always before you as well.
- He comes up with the Excel spreadsheet
on the best technique.
(Gigguk laughing)
And it's like, all right,
I just wanna play the game(indistinct)
- Yeah, yeah and you're just
standing there being like,
what buttons do I press?(laughing)
Like, I don't even know
any of these songs.
- It's time, crisis.
- And it's always like,
it's always the worst
(indistinct) as well,
because you know there's
people standing around you.
- [Gigguk] Oh no!
- Judging you so hard.
It's like, look at this(indistinct).
- Especially when you're
like a guest there,
everyone's gonna look at you like,
wow, Joey kind of sucks at that.
- Yeah, I'm definitely gonna bring this up
at they panel later.(laughing)
you sucked at DDR,
Do you have any comments about that?
- Yeah, I suck at DDR.
- Yeah, that's what I love
about like Japanese arcades,
is that you can just spend,
you can just lose so many hours in there,
and it's really easy because it's..
- Oh, and you get the cards.
- Yeah, I was going to
talk about the cards.
- Sorry, sorry.(crosstalk)
- Like basically,
actually you explain Joey,
cause you're the one who did it for me.
So you probably know the
process better than me.
- So, different machines
are owned by I guess,
different rhythm game
companies or whatever.
- Yeah.
- And you can, if you get so good at it,
you can buy these cards for
like 300 yen, which is nothing,
It's like $3 and you print them out,
and you can save your progress on it,
because it's a public rhythm game.
So if you just put the money
in, you're treated as a guest.
So you records all records
for whatever stage you do.
- High scores.(crosstalk)
- High scores, that kind of stuff,
doesn't get saved because
you're just a guest.
- Yeah.
- So if you get so invested
in a particular rhythm game,
or a number of rhythm games.
You can buy these cards and to you know,
save your records and stuff like that.
And you can, a lot of
Japanese people I know
like share it online to flex
on each other essentially.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Yeah, they do.
- I recommend getting it any way,
because there are some rhythm
games, like the piano one,
that if you don't have a card,
they're going to make you
sit through the tutorial,
and there's no way to skip it.
- Exactly.
- Like I remember, I really enjoyed it.
I went to the arcade on
three separate occasions,
and for the first like three minutes
I was just sitting there being like...
- I remember I finished
up my first two songs.
I'm like, you don't have the tutorial?
(laughing)
- I was still doing the
tutorial every time.
So I was like, I've
gotta get a fucking card.
I need a card, yeah.
- And the good thing as
well with those cards is
that not only are they cheap,
but a lot of the cards,
the first game that you do
with the card is usually free.
So you actually make that money back.
- Is it really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So with Groove Coaster at least,
when you get a, its called a
NESCA card, cause I guess..
- Yeah, there's NESCA and
then there's a few other ones.
- Then there's the
Bandai one,(indistinct).
- I think yeah, I have that.
- So with the NESCA card at least,
the first game of Groove
Coaster you play is free.
Because you just put
that money into the card.
- [Gigguk] Right.
- which I think is a nice compromise
because it doesn't feel
like you just, you know
you're paying extra to save
your progress essentially.
- And you can, like you'll only
have a set amount of stages
as a guest.
- Yeah.
- And if you, you know, level
up, you learn more stages.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
It's just cool to like
go back to an arcade,
you know every so often just..
- My favorite anime song.
- Yeah, so I've gotta
triple S this stage, man.
I just have to, I have to invest more.
- They have Undertale on
Groove Coaster, right?
- Yeah, they have intel soundtrack.
- [Gigguk] Oh sit.(laughing)
- Dude, I can do level 12 Megalovania,
like Triple S, I was
pretty proud of myself,
I'm not gonna lie.
- It's so cool, Cause on
Groove coast they have like,
Special animations just
for the Undertale song.
- Oh really?
- So it looks like an Undertale game,
playing out on the game.
- Oh, no, that's every
song that they have.
Even all the Vocaloid stuff
as well, they use like,
the music videos for it.
And that's what I love
about Groove Coaster,
because every stage actually
looks really unique as well,
because it has to match the song.
- Have you tried using
your card at(indistinct)
in America, have you ever tried that?
- No.
- I should try that.
- That'd be pretty cool.
If you're at a convention
and you just(crosstalk).
Whip out the card, right?
- Yeah.
- (indistinct) the internet?
- I gotta, flex on these
people that I Triple S
Megalovania level 12, you know.
- Oh you still have all stages.
- Oh, how'd you guys feel
about like the UFO machines,
or like what, like the prize
machines here in Japan?
- Archie is fucking amazing at it,
and I don't know how she is.
- Because, what really
surprised me is that,
in most, in everywhere else,
it's kind of like a lock.
Kind of like a lock base.
But in here I see people
who are just really good
at these machines and
they can actually turn it
into a profit because then
they just sell the figures,
or whatever you get or buy.
- That's a huge industry as well.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Its a big deal.
Like a lot of the stores
(indistinct) selling crank game stuff.
- Yeah.(indistinct)
- I just don't understand how
people can get good at that,
because Archie, every
time we go to an arcade,
Archie is always just like,
fuck the rhythm games,
I'm just gonna go to the crane games,
to just get random shit.
But every time I try it,
and she's standing next
to me, she's always like,
Oh no, you should move
them all to the right.
I'm like, how do you know that?(laughing)
I was just fucking going forward.
Just like a whole like
secret thing where it's like,
yeah you have to aim as
slightly to the left,
so that it drags the
plushy closer to the hole.
I'm just like, how do
you figure that shit out?
- I just wanna go beep beep and pick up
I don't wanna think about this.
(Gigguk and Joey laughing)
I wanna just play it.
- I guess you have to if you wanna like,
not spend as much money.
But if I really really want
the thing in the crane,
I'll just go to the shop next door,
that probably is selling
it used for like 800 yen.
Which is way cheaper than
what it would have...
- Every time we to an arcade in Akihabra
There's always the store
next to it is selling
the exact thing you're
trying to gamble for.
- But if in Japan, if you mess up,
and you put enough money in the machine,
the staff will come over and be like,
hey you want help?
- We feel kind of bad, you've spent like
how many thousands of yens on this.
- Which is why like when I
have friends who are doing it,
who are fucking up loads,
and they've put like 20 bucks, I'm like,
Put like 10 more bucks, and
then I'll call the staff over.
- Yeah.
- And if you do that,
normally they'll place it.
They'll pick it up,
literally put it on the box,
and just require you to like tap it.
Like they'll pretty
much set it up for you.
- Baby mode, baby mode activated.
- Yeah, literally baby mode.
Pro tip, if you come to
Japan, just fuck up a lot.
- Use your (indistinct) card and be like,
I don't know how to do this.
(cross talk)
- And they'll be like,
all right, I got you man.
- Man, damn.
Have you ever seen a crane game
at the conventions in America?
- No, I haven't actually.
- I've seen them, but I've
always been scared to try them.
- I guess, cause you
can set the crane game
to how difficult you want it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
And just knowing how like a lot of,
at least American crane
games that I played,
how they might as well just be like,
they might as well not be a claw.
- It's basically just a slot
machine with a claw attached.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, exactly.
(crosstalk)
I'd rather put my money
into an actual slot machine,
than a crane game.
- Which I would not rather
do anyway.(laughter)
- But no, there's like a
lot of different games,
that you just don't see
anywhere else in arcades.
Like I don't know why there's always,
there's always a Faygo,
like section that's like..
- It's not just one machine,
there's an entire row.
- There's a row of Faygo
machines in every fucking arcade,
I swear to God.
- And those machines, have
you played on those machines?
- I haven't yet.
- They are fucking expensive.
- What is it?
I've never played the game.
- The cards, right?
- So they're expensive because
you can print out physical
cards of the waifus
that you get in Faygo.
- Yo for real.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Connor] You didn't know that?
- Oh, shit.
- [Joey] I'm surprised.
- (indistinct) cause you'll
be broke, don't, don't.
- So, Nobi, one of my best friends here,
he is like a super
heavy, like Faygo player.
I mean he used to be.
- AKA he has no money.
- AKA, he's broke, so..
- I don't need to give fate anymore money.
- [Connor] No you don't, don't.
- Don't tell me this, don't tell me this.
- But from what I saw, cause
I went to an arcade with him
and he was like, Oh can I just
go into the Faygo machines?
And I'm like, yeah, actually cause
I've always wanted to know what they were.
I've always walked past them.
And yeah, it's like a double screen.
It's like a giant DS essentially,
where the bottom screen
is like a touchscreen
and you have these packet of cards,
and you can essentially use
cards to summon fake characters.
- That's so cool, oh my God!
You are telling me this
and I'm just like..
- Its like you use the
fake characters to like,
beat like a certain quest.
It's kind of like Dragon
Quest with fake characters.
And if you beat a certain quest,
and depending on how you beat it,
then you can unlock different waifus,
and you can actually print out
the waifus from the machine.
- Oh no!
- Don't tell him this.
- Just to play one game is
already expensive enough.
But of course, they take money to like
actually print out the cards.
So it's just like so much money
for the franchise right now.
And I know after today
you're gonna go to one.
- You're just gonna see me in a week,
and(indistinct) guys I've
spent way too much money.
(Joey laughing)
- (indistinct) coming in with like a deck.
- Like why did you tell me this?
- I'm surprised you never went on it,
considering you made
the whole Gacha video.
- I mean like, because of quarantine.
Like it was quarantine
that started my process
for the Gacha video.
So I haven't actually been to an arcade
since quarantine started.
So I've just been playing Faygo, and so..
- You know what we're
doing after this podcast.
(Gigguk laughing)
We're going to an arcade that
has a Faygo machine and..
- It just(indistinct) like Skylanders,
but for questionable adults.
(laughter)
you know what I mean, like
that's what it sounds like.
You can (indistinct) the cards.
Oh, okay.
- I mean, to be fair, it's Pretty fun.
- I mean , that's basically
Gacha games and(indistinct).
- [Connor] Okay.
- I mean, you're just, you're
just collecting P and G's,
or cards or whatever.
(Joey laughing)
- Literal P and G is
printed out this time.
- Wait, wait, so you're telling me
that we're not just collecting P and Gs,
but they're physical
and printed out, bruh.
- Laminated cards.
- Once a P an G always a P and G.
(Gigguk and Joey laughing)
- Man, do you know the coolest game
I ever saw on Arcadia here was?
You know Typing Of The Dead?
It's actually on arcade machines.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, it's in Akihabra.
It's on like the, one
of the Sega buildings.
- They have like four Sega buildings.
- Yeah, one of them, one of them.
There's the typing of the dead mode.
- Yeah.
- They actually have a Typing Of The Dead.
So it's house of the dead,
but you type all the...
- Yeah, yeah.
So what, its like a keyboard there?
- It's a keyboard, two
keyboards(indistinct).
- Oh that's so cool.
- It's so fucking cool, I
need to get a picture of it.
- Yeah, that's so cool.
- I remember being next to the
game where you tip the table.
(laughter)
There's an arcade game in
Japan, where all you do is like,
you have to tip this
table as hard as possible.
- You know, in like American arcades,
they have the punching machines.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- It's that, but instead
of punching something,
you just lift something.
- (laughing) You lift the table.
- You flip it as hard as you can.
- On screen right now,
there'll be a reference.
But yeah, it's really fun and cool.
- It's very fun,
- But it's kind of expensive,
cause you get one flip.
- Yeah.
- And then you better
make that flip count.
- Better make that flip count.(laughing)
- That sounds fucking amazing.
- Yeah.
- It's good, its good.
- Only in Japan(indistinct).
- Only in Japan.
- Where else would you wanna flip a table?
Like
- Where else can you flip a table
in real life and just get away with them?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You don't have to clean up the mess.
- Not only get away with
it, but will be rewarded.
(laughter)
- Well done,(indistinct) high score.
- In your like, home countries,
did you ever have like
these arcades at home,
where they would like have this
one Japanese arcade machine,
and like everyone would be on it.
- In Wales, they didn't
but in London they did.
- Yeah, in London there's a few.
I remember there was one
arcade machine collect..
I think it was Bishy Bashy.
- I love that game.
(crosstalk)
- Yeah, but like in London it
was like a really, really old,
like arcade.
- It was beaten up.
And in here, like I didn't
realize there was like,
new iterated versions of it.
Yeah, Bishy Bashy is a lot of fun.
It's just basically like
Mario party on crack.
(laughter)
- With only one mechanic.
- Yeah.
- It's like, you have to press
your button in certain ways,
but one button.
- I mean Bishy Bashy means to hit.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Cause there's some, some
games you are just like...
- Yeah.
- Like I'm spamming
and I love those games.
It's a fun game, you should play it,
if you ever come here.
- Yeah, it's super fun.
- Yeah, basically, I feel like
one of the web experiences
is go to Akihabara,
but I feel like you'd be missing half that
by not going to an arcade as well.
- Yeah, and that's the good thing
about Japanese arcades, right?
Is that you don't have to go
to Akihabara to experience it.
- [Gigguk] No you don't.
- They are literally everywhere.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Its definitely like a
different gaming experience
from normal gaming.
In a way that like is hard
to quantify the value of.
I guess cause as a gamer, right?
I love spending 10 hours
a day playing video games,
but I can't spend more
than like four hours
in an arcade in Japan.
- Yeah.
- It's hard.
- Yeah, it depends on the game for me.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- I mean, I think nowadays..
- It's hot as well.
- Yeah.
- Oh, it's so fucking hot.
- And If you're on the
floor where they smoke,
like, cause there's always one floor,
where you're allowed to smoke.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God, that floor reeks.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean, I feel like nowadays
I probably have a little
bit of an easier time
because I've kind of
diversified my rhythm game.
- Bring headphones, bring headphones.
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, bring headphones.
Bring your own headphones as well.
- You need an aux cord basically.
- But if you don't,
then you're going to try
and play a rhythm game
while you're hearing 50 other rhythms.
- Yeah.
- At the same time.
- I think that's why it's
so hard for me to sit down
or stand is before for like months,
I didn't use headphones.
I couldn't get into it.
But when I put headphones
on, I just do my thing.
- You're just in your zone, yeah.
- For like maybe like an hour,
but I can't sit there for too long.
- It feels so good.
Cause I remember the first
time I tried the piano machine,
and I didn't have headphones
and I'm just like,
I can't even hear the music.
So I'm just, I'm just
playing, press the color.
(laughter)
You know what I mean?
Like, there's no rhythm to this game.
I'm just smashing what I see on screen.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But like with headphones I'm like,
oh, this feels good, this is...
- Yeah, exactly.
- I feel like a fucking
master at playing piano.
I'm here, I'm just like, like smashing.
- Oh, pretty colors.
- So when it comes to
like actual anime games,
like games that are based off of anime.
- Right.
- Which ones have you done?
Cause we briefly mentioned
about the Dragon Ball fighting games,
or the Naruto fighting games,
but have you guys played any recently?
- I don't think so,
cause the only games,
anime games I can think of
that I played recently
are all like mobile games,
or like I Gacha games and you know,
do they really count as games?
I mean, yes.
- They are kind of in a
league of their own, right?
- Yeah, I feel like that's
a separate genre, right?
- I'm a pure multi-player slave.
So I think just like no anime
games and like a multiplayer.
- Because the recent
anime game that I played,
which apparently no one fucking played was
the Fist Of The North Star game.
- Oh, cause it was like
a skin on a Yakuza game.
- Basically it was done by
the people who did the Yakuza.
(crosstalk)
And I mean I fucking love
this in a North star.
So when I saw that and I was like,
Oh it's basically just a Yakuza game.
I was like, hell yeah!
I played it, that game is so fucking fun.
No one played it.
- If you like the Yakuza
games, you'll (indistinct).
- But here's the thing,
I've never played a Yakuza game.
- Oh, okay.
- I've only heard about Yakuza games,
because a lot of my friends like it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I was just more drawn to
the fact that it was a first
in an all-star game and
it looked fucking amazing.
- I saw a clip he's like
(mimicking screams).
- Yeah, dude, you can do the
(speaks in foreign language)
in the game.
- Oh, my God.
- And I was like, yes!
It was so fun, so good, I love it.
Yeah, but..
- Did that get localized over to the West?
- I'm pretty sure it did.
- okay.
- I saw a few of my
(indistinct) friends playing it.
- Okay.
- Yeah I saw a few
reviews when it came out,
and everybody was just kind of like,
yeah, it's a Yakuza game.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Yeah, do you guys remember
when Jump Falls was announced?
- Oh my God. (laughter)
- The shit storm that caused.
- That was hilarious.
- Oh my God.
It was the beautiful irony,
that a game about anime characters
had some of the worst cuts
scenes imaginable.(crosstalk)
- I just remember the scene where,
I think it was freezer or
something, just like floating up.
(laughter)
- T posing and he's like,
all right I have to go guys.
I have to go.
- That whole game is junk bro.
- Oh, that's the problem
with anime games recently,
because I don't know
if the game will be out
by the time this episode is out.
But right now I'm doing a
video where I collect a bunch
of old retro anime games
that never made it out of Japan.
- Yeah, yeah.
- To like kind of review anime games,
because like the general consensus I feel
with anime based games,
at least in the West,
is that they're very
much a modern endeavor.
It's like only recently that now
anime is becoming a lot
more of a mainstream thing
in the West that they're
finally starting to capitalize
on the Western market.
And, but you know, in retrospect,
anime games have been
around since like the NES.
- Yeah, yeah.
- (indistinct) period.
They just never made it out of Japan.
But it's so unfortunate that now,
all these like people in
the West who love anime,
are finally starting to get
kind of a glimpse into like
anime based games.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- And yet you get shit like Jump Force,
and One Piece World Seeker.
- You got one piece game,
I saw a footage of that.
Oh my God, the frame rate was garbage.
- Dude, I was kind of looking
forward to that game too.
Cause I'm like maybe
finally we'll get a good
One Piece adventure game.
No, we did not.
- I mean the problem with anime games,
a lot of anime games,
is they just look like
a quick cash grab.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- They want to make it look triple A,
but they're not willing to
put the money in.(crosstalk).
- Like I remember, I
think it was last year,
or the year before there was
like my hero academia game.
They all look the same,
they all look junky as fuck.
- Yeah.
- And yeah, I dunno like I haven't like,
and then you read some of the reviews,
and nothing really sells you on this game,
versus this hey this actual triple A game,
or something that has
nothing to do with anime.
Like I don't have enough
time to play games enough
as it is, let alone play..
- [Connor] I'm not playing a shitty game.
- Yeah.(chuckling)
- If you're going to get me off like,
the games I'm cripplingly addicted to,
it better be fucking good.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
It better be oak knights.(laughing)
- It better be oak knights,
Breath of The wild was one game
that like managed to tear me away.
- Oh, yeah of course, everybody,
everybody(indistinct).
- The only thing that tears me away,
from like league of legends
is another multiplier thing
where I could just keep
grinding and(indistinct).
- I remember when I first
played Breath Of The Wild,
cause when I first
played Breath Of The wild
was when I first came to Japan.
And I remember it was
great because I was like,
it was my first time experiencing Japan,
and seeing all the stuff
and all I can think of is,
I just want to go home, so
I could just...(laughter)
- I had the exact same thing.
- I need to get to that temple man.
There is a part of the
map that is unexplored,
I want to hit that out.
- I remember playing in the bathtub.
Like I was so addicted
that even my bathing,
I had to be playing it.
- You had to utilize every
amount of time that you have.
- I remember, I was in
that fucking fire dungeon,
the wind dungeon thing with..
- Yeah.
- Dude it's terrible.
- I recently during, at the
beginning of quarantine,
I decided to get back
into Breath Of The Wild.
But this time I played it on pro mode.
- Wow, you're a real gamer,
you are such a gamer.
- I know, epic gamer gold moment,
but the only difference between
pro mode and regular mode,
is that on the main HUD,
like, you know how, when you're
playing Breath Of The Wild
there's like the mini map in the corner,
like the temperature, time of day.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Pro mode basically,
takes all of that away,
and just shows you your heart.
- Right.
- So you're forced to
explore and look around.
And when I played it, I was like,
this is how the game is
supposed to be played,
because I discovered more
things in the photo file.
- (indistinct) This is the correct way.
(laughter)
- No, legit because I discovered more shit
in the first 10 minutes of pro mode,
than I did in the first couple
of hours of regular games.
- Damn, what the fuck were
you doing in the regular game?
- Because in the regular game mode,
you have the mini-map, right?
- Yeah.
- So you're forced to like
go to the closer shiny thing
that you see on the mini map.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Whereas on pro mode,
you have to fucking look
around and I was like,
Oh shit I didn't know there
was a temple right here,
like right under my feet,
because I'm too fucking worried
about going to this tower,
that the game is telling you to..
- Joey is a pro gamer.
(laughter)
- Dude, at that moment, I was like,
this is epic gamer go mode right here.
- On the topic of anime games though,
how'd you guys feel about visual novels?
- I fucking love them.
- Yeah, yeah, have you ever played one?
- No I have not played visual novel?
- I had a moment during high school
where all I played was visual novels.
- I remember I've booted
them up several times.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- And every single time I
get about five minutes in,
I'm like, hey this is
just a book, (laughter)
in disguise, trynna trick me into reading.
- This is just a book with extra pictures.
- Like it's a book with extra steps.
- It's like a novel, but
there's like visuals to it.
What the fuck?
- I think the best example I
ever heard was my friend saying
this is just an audio book with pictures.
(laughter)
- Some of them don't
even have voice acting.
- It's an audio book with pictures ,
but the main character never
has the voice. (laughing)
Because they want you to immerse.
- I don't know, I'm sure
there's a lot of people
that are at home who are
watching this as well
who holds her in the same boat as me
where I'm like, it's too (indistinct)
- I don't blame anybody,
Who says that they can't
get into visual novels.
- Is it in the same category as gaming?
Like, it can't be, right?
- No.
- That's what I was gonna say,
cause like, I'm a gamer.(crosstalk)
- There's like different
levels, I feel because like
okay so like..
- Like in a game, I hear you.(chuckling)
- No, cause like it took
me like years because,
as a kid I would play on my DS.
Like I was a Nintendo kid, right.
So I had like a D S, would
like play on that a lot.
And then it took me years
to realize, wait a minute,
Phoenix Wright is just a visual novel.
- I never liked Phoenix Wright.
- Did you know?
- He was trynna trick me into thinking.
- Oh I love Phoenix Wright.
- I love Phoenix Wright.
- How dare you trick me into thinking?
Let me shoot things.
- Where is that high octane
gameplay that I signed up for?
- Where is the action?
I didn't come here to think,
if I wanted to think I'd play..
- I didn't come here to read.
- I would have played Professor Layton,
if I wanted to think.
- Hey professor, Layton is
also a really good game.
(crosstalk)
- I would look at it, I love puzzle games.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But that's why when I
tried to play Phoenix Wright,
I'm like this isn't a puzzle game,
they're trying to trick me into thinking,
I'm using my brain, I'm
just reading the whole time.
- Weirdly enough, I got into visual novels
because I really heavily
gone into Arrow Gaze.
- Oh my God.
- (clapping) Yes, yes, yes.
- I started with Arrow Gaze and then..
- That's my brother, that's my brother.
- I started with Arrow Gaze obviously,
because I am a 13 year old
horny boy on(indistinct).
- What, the first visual
novel that you played?
- Why don't you just watch
porn if you are horny?
- I did.
- You were you in Google,
you have all the Google,
and you think I want to read the porn.
(crosstalk)
- Okay, okay, before you get
to the porn, you need to like,
it doesn't feel as good if you just,
if they just hand it to you, right.
(crosstalk)
You earned that shit.
- You don't read the porn,
you experience the porn.
- So how old were you
guys when you've gotten
into this festival?
- Arrow Gaze?
- Yeah.
- Like 14.
- 13, 14.
- When I was 14, right?
My mum could have come in the
room at any second, right?
This needed to be like
special ops precision.
I needed to get in and out,
and get the deep done, because you know,
did you have like two
floors through the house?
- No, I have one floor.
No, no, I had two floors, but
we're all on the same floor.
- Okay so my bedroom is
on the second, right?
- Right.
- Where I had about a five second window,
where I could here the stairs creaking.
I didn't know which
room she was going into,
but just in case I had
to prepare every time.
- During those five seconds,
it's just the Mission Impossible
theme playing in your head.
It's like what do I do?
- I had like a whole
setup ready just in case,
my mum was going to
walk in the room, right?
And it was playing with..
How did you have the time
to get into a story, right?
And without any of your parents
finding you watching porn?
- Because I was one of those kids
that had a lock on his door.
- Your parents give you a lock?
- Yeah.
- Bro, my parents would
never give me a lock.
- Actually like the only computer we had
in my household was like
the family computer.
- Yeah, I'd use the family laptop.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was watching porn
on the family laptop.
- Because my dad was been working
in an IT company for 30 years,
so he gave everybody
like our own computers.
- He had it on easy mode.(laughter)
- Yeah.
- He didn't have to like walk
around schedules or anything.
- But like, I knew because
my parents would always,
they would always be out in several like,
specific hours of the day for work.
So I'd be like, okay, it's
Arrow Gaze time.(laughter)
- I would just like 10
minutes, get the deed done,
go back to gaming.
- I don't even remember what
the first Arrow Gaze was
that I played, it was(indistinct).
- I remember what it was for me.
It was called the Sagara
Family or something like that.
- That sounds ghetto or something.
- How I discovered it, right?
This is like going before Arrow Gaze
but it was technically Arrow Gaze.
Did you guys ever go through that phase
where you're just playing shitty,
like henti visual novels on new grounds?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Frank's adventure?(laughter)
That was the shit.
Are you kidding me?(laughter)
(indistinct)
(crosstalk)
- Henti sex kid or something like that?
- I feel like this was two hobbies,
that you shouldn't have
combined at a young age.
Like I wanted a game.
- That just like blew the
biggest wave of nostalgia in me.
- Yeah, I knew(indistinct).
- Of course I do.
Oh you go onto new grounds
and you see that like
red letter a, I was like,
it's my game boys let's go.
(laughter)
It was so good, it was
like it was so shitty
because you know this was made by like,
one dude living in like
the middle of fucking like,
you know Winnie Peg.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah.
- In like his mom's basement being like,
I'm gonna make a really
shitty like hentai flash game.
- But like, as a kid at that time,
that was like the only
exposure you can get.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So you were just like, holy shit.
- I was too afraid at that moment,
to like go on to Google images.
Cause I didn't know how to
search for that shit, right?
(crosstalk)
- So you're telling me, you
know how to find porn games,
but you didn't know how to find porn?
- Yeah because on new grounds
they have an entire section.
I don't know if it's still to this day,
but back then on new grounds,
there was an entire adult section
that clearly just said "Adult".
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- So you knew that,
if you clicked on that
part of the website,
every game or animation that came up,
was going to be of that caliber.
- Exactly, and they were all hentai games.
- They were all hentai games.
- Why don't you watch porn?
I don't understand.
- Because you don't
know how to look it up.
- What do you mean?
You know what porn is..
- No, Because porn hub
didn't exist, you know..
- Wait, when did porn hub come around?
- I don't know, Like..
- when I was like 16, maybe.
This is (indistinct)
but this was before the age of streaming.
- Okay, like in anime
boomer, right?(laughter)
- No, like so what do you
do if you need to find porn,
but you can't stream it.
When did Google get popularized?
Cause I remember back then
I was probably using Yahoo,
or Ask Jeeves.
- Yahoo, Ask Jeeves.
- Jeeves, where is the porn?
- Where is Brazzers Jeeves, I'm wondering.
- Cause the reason I
discovered Sagara family,
was because you know,
in those hentai visual
like the new ground visual novels,
you don't (crosstalk).
You know what I'm talking about Connor?
- I know what you're talking about.
- They would always like,
the porn part would always be these gifs,
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
and then I saw one of the
comments and they were like,
they sourced the gif.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, yeah. Yeah.
And so that's what introduced
me to the world of Arrow Gaze.
- That's how I found my
first Arrow Gaze as well,
because I played like Frank's adventure
or whatever the fuck it was.
And there was a section where it's like
you walk into a cinema, but
like the cinema is mosaic
and you have to get like a special item
from someone to like, unlock the mosaic.
And when you finally did,
it was this like gif of
this like, oh, this image.
It wasn't even a gif because
I was from an Arrow Gaze.
It was just this gif or this PNG of just
this like really old
like nineties Arrow Gaze.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah.
- And my 13 year old
brain was like, fuck yeah.
What is that?
Give me the sauce.
(crosstalk)
And I scroll to the comments,
and of course there was that
one also a horny on main
13 year old, and he was like,
hey, at this part of the game,
where she from?
- Where does this image come from?
- And of course there
was this culture boy,
who was like, my man's, I got you.
Probably from Reddit
or fortune at the time,
he was like, I got you bro.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I came from the A board.
That's where all the source is.
And then I would finally look it up.
- Yeah.
- And of course back then, you know,
the wild wild West of the internet.
You could get games like that very easily.
- You can get it easily.
You just took like two
millennia to download.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Cause I remember like because
I could only download it
when my parents were out.
- What is two gigabyte download, son?
(laughter)
- It was like gigabytes, and I'm like,
Oh, this is gonna take time.
So back then, like I would have
to like plan this shit out.
This is like scheduled.
Okay yeah, you had a bell.
- (indistinct) special ops operation.
(crosstalk) You had about
40 different dot RAR files,
and you need to download
them one at a time.(laughter)
Cause you couldn't
download one massive pile.
You had to download like..
- That hit too close to home for me, men.
And I hated it when you
would go into the website,
and it's like, you can only download,
you would download part one of 76 raw file
and you finally get it, and
you realize it's like 200 Meg.
It's like, all right,
that won't take too long,
and you download it and you
go to download part two,
and it's like, you have to wait 15 minutes
for the next one.(laughter)
I'm just like god damn it.
- So like..
- These are struggles
I do not identify with.
- So like when I actually
done it and sometimes like
one of the parts would be
missing, and it was just the most,
it was the most angry
moment you can think of.
Cause you've downloaded 40 files,
you just need one more file.
You, go on WinRAR you try to
extract it, there's an error.
What the fuck do you do?
- Exactly.
- I remember so many times I would..
(crosstalk)
- I remember so many times.
- I just wanted that last piece.
- Because when you've invested
so much time downloading this
and there's just one file.
There were so many hentai
games I've never played,
cause there's just one file missing.
And I couldn't find the problem.
- Because that's the
problem, it's like unlike,
you know, previously we talked
about like how part three
out of eight of this
anime movie was missing.
You could still watch
the other seven parts.
But with Arrow Gaze, with WinRaR,
you missing one part you
can't play any of them.
- It just sounds like
fucking Harry Potter hunting
down the(indistinct).
- Like I just realized
how close that story was
to the YouTube story that
we told a few weeks ago
about watching animate in parts.
But imagine, if you're missing one part,
you just don't watch the
entire series.(laughter)
- You can't watch the entire movie.
It's like you're missing part three,
you can't open part one.
- Sounds like a message from
God to be a good Christian boy.
- And that's why when all those parts
did successfully download
and did successfully extract,
and you booted it up the
moment a window popped up
and it wasn't like spyware.
It was just like, yes.
Now I can finally put in the time,
that I'd spent so long trying to get,
and I did put in the
time no matter how shitty
the Arrow Gaze was.
Cause I remember my first couple of,
I didn't know what a good
Arrow Gaze was at the time.
I just downloaded whatever
the fuck the I saw
on Huguenots at the time.
- It was a victory.
The fact that you got it
working and you were like,
I'm gonna play this and
I'm gonna fucking enjoy it.
And it was amazing.
- I'm gonna 100% complete
this shit if it kills me.
- Damn, I was just playing(indistinct)
(laughter)
You guys go and you guys saw you
go through a fucking mission
just to get something working.
- But it was so worth it.
- Just to see like what,
one third of a tootie tit?
- That's what it was, men.
- Cause that was like how hard it was,
to get porn back in the day.
- Like go go rune scape,
selling GF, buying GF?
- Actually I have a funny story on that.
- Oh shit, okay.
- No, no, because like, okay,
this is like when I was a kid, right?
And like when you first discover,
like the concept of like
sex and porn and like,
I didn't like we had dial
up internet back then.
- Yeah, same, same.
- But like this was going back
when I was like nine, 10, you know,
before I could really like
have time to work on a computer
and everything like that.
So I would like the only way I could get
anything close to that was
by watching like late night
TV shows right in the UK.
So, what I try to do as a kid was,
I would record shows on my VHS.
- I did that as well.
- okay, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, but there's was this one show,
cause I looked at the TV guide,
there was this one show.
- Oh I think you did what I did.
- There was this one show that was like,
Ooh this sounds spicy as a kid,
I'm like, Ooh, this sounds
exactly what I'm looking for.
It was a late night TV
show aired at like 12.
- Is it, can I say the title?
- Okay.
- Is it called Babe Station?
- No, no, no.
- That was the one in UK.
- Let's talk about that later.
- I probably would have
enjoyed Babe Station more.
The show was called, Sex In The City.
(laughter)
So me being a nine year old kid,
thinking I'm about to get porn right now.
And then I set my VHS up,
I go to sleep the VHS records,
and I've never been more
disappointed as a kid.(laughter)
Like, imagine it as a kid,
you think you're about to get full on sex,
for the first time.
- In the city.
- In the city
- And the city, right?
And you just get a bunch of girls
talking about Dick and shoes.
I was like, what is this?
This is false advertising.
Do you know how much
effort I had to put in
to record this show
and this is what I get.
- I remember as well,
I was like a 12 year old, 13 year old.
And just hearing that like my mom's friend
whose favorite show was Sex in the City,
I was like, that's not
very Christian of you,
what the fuck?(laughter)
Man, adults are scary.
(indistinct) hold on.
We got to hear about what
the fuck Babe Station is.
- So Babe Station is a
channel in the UK, right?
And it would air, like what?
Like 11 30?
- Yeah, yeah, something like.
- (indistinct) Just like girls
on a couch, like half naked.
And then they would
occasionally take off that bra.
But the whole time you
wouldn't hear anything.
You would just here like porn music,
but they were calling someone,
you could call in and talk to them.
- Right.
- And there's some good videos on YouTube,
People trolling them, right.
That's pretty funny, but
I was like a 14 year old,
and I was like, damn.
- It's basically chatter bates before..
- On TV.
- But you can't hear what they're saying.
- Yeah.
- Because they're talking to someone.
Occasionally they would let
you hear the audio.(indistinct)
- Yeah, yeah.(laughter)
- This is where you could be having,
that was 12-year old me,
I'm never gonna call them.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh my God, yeah, cause I remember
after family guy would
air, so I would like
tape a family guy episode,
just to leave it running,
you know(chuckling).
- Just nonchalantly, yeah.
I noticed actually that
light UK TV at night,
really like holds (indistinct)
(crosstalk)
- Porn on so many channels(indistinct)
- Because Archie and I
only recently discovered,
thanks to Martia, about
the show Naked Attraction.
(crosstalk)
Yeah, you showed that to me.
- Yeah.
Naked attraction is basically this..
- You've seen this?
- I have not.
- The show, it's a show on UK televisual.
I don't know what time it
is, I assume it's like..
- It's on channel four about like 9:00 PM.
- But basically it's this game
show where a guy or a girl
would come onto the show,
looking for a boyfriend or a girlfriend.
- Right.
And in the case with
like say a boy coming on,
looking for a girlfriend,
what they would do is
they would show five different girls,
but they would be butt naked.
- Completely naked.
- Seriously?
- Yeah like, no mosaic, completely naked.
And what they would do is they
would start from the down up.
So what they would do is,
they would first show below the belt.
- [Gigguk] Right.
- And then the guy was..
- And you could see everything.
- You could see everything.
- Oh, okay.
- And the guy will go, would be like, hmm,
okay, I like that genitalia.
I don't like that genitalia.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And then at that point,
just from looking at like
the genitalia, they have to
be like no to this person.
And then they would go up to the tits
and then they would show the face,
and then that would reveal the voice.
And at the end, when there's
the last two people remaining,
like last two contestants remaining,
the guy or girl who like
originally came onto the show,
they have to also come out naked.
- [Gigguk] Oh.
- And then, as they're naked they have to
pick one of the two and
then they go on a date.
- It's really awful.
- And I watched it, and
Archie and I were like,
this is the most amazing
show I've ever seen.
- Yeah, it's called
Naked Attraction I think?
- Naked attraction, yeah.
And there's clips of it on YouTube.
- Yeah, yeah.
- How are they getting away with it?
- There's entire seasons of it on YouTube,
and I don't understand how
they're getting away with it.
Like we get like,
I guarantee this episode
is gonna get(indistinct)
and yet whole episodes of naked attraction
can be on YouTube, and YouTube is like,
well, I guess it's a TV show.
So I guess it's okay.
Yeah, but I don't know.
I thought I was going to hate it at first,
because just from the concept,
it sounds absolutely trashy
- But it makes you like
the worst person ever.
- Oh, yeah.
- Cause you're like, oh wow,
their feet are slightly disformed,
I'm gonna have to(indistinct).
- It's not even their feet, it's like,
Oh, that pussy is a little mangled.
- Oh God.
- Oh my God, oh.
- And you have to say that
in front of the person,
I'm like, I would never
be able to(indistinct).
- I don't think I have the
self-confidence(indistinct).
(crosstalk)
- But these are like just
chill people, normal people,
and they go on and they're just like,
(indistinct)just spice it up a little bit.
There's spicing it up love,
and then there's getting naked
in front of the entire
country, there's an in between.
- I'm like, is it really worth it
for the 15 minutes of fame?
If you have to show your
naked body(indistinct)
- And they show you a little
bit of a date afterwards
and they are always fucking awful.
- It's so awkward, it's so awkward.
- It's like, hi, hi(indistinct)
- So, yeah. I hear you think
(indistinct) win tower defense?
How'd you go on a day after you've just
Commented on their like
weirdly shaped penis.
- Yeah, exactly.
My favorite though is when
they do finally pick a winner
and it's that awkward hug.
- Oh, they do an awkward hug.
- They do an awkward hug
to the person who lost.
- Like oh, thank you, you chose me.
- But it's so funny how
back both of their like..
(crosstalk)
That their genitalia don't
touch as they hug each other.
And the host is just watching it.
And she's just like,
all right, fuck off now.
- (indistinct) that woman,
she does all the channel four shows.
She did a Big Brother.
- Oh, Davina McCall?
- Yeah, Davina McCall.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And she's really big name in the UK.
- I mean, she's a good host.
- It's kinda weird that
she kinda got relegated
to the see team.
- I didn't know she did big brother,
but now I know that it
totally makes sense.
- Yeah, going back to
visual novels though,
we got very sidetracked.
What was it like the first visual novel
that you played then,
that you would consider
not going through your trashy
Arrow Gaze teenager phase.
Oh my God, this is hentai.
- I think the first one I played
knowing exactly what it was
and enjoying the fuck out of it was Kanon.
- Kanon, oh okay.
- Yeah, because I think
it was weird, right?
I kind of discovered
the Kanon visual novel
after I watched air.
- [Gigguk] Right.
- What is this stuff by the way?
Cause I have no idea(indistinct)
- It's from the same guy.
- Its from the same
people who made Clan ad.
- I know that, yeah.
- So before clan ad visual
arts made a number of games,
One of them being Air,
which I watched the anime of
and I first discovered
what visual arts is.
And I was like, Oh, I want to see,
oh, this is based off a game.
I couldn't find, I remember
I couldn't find the
air visual novel anywhere.
- [Gigguk] Right.
- But I found Kanon,
which is the first game
that they ever made.
So I played Kanon,
and of course, if you
know the story of Kanon,
I cry like a bitch, obviously.
But I was like, the first
time in my life, I was like,
wow, visual novels are
really fucking long.
(laughter) Because
Kanon not only has like,
seven different endings, but
just to get to one ending,
it takes about 30 hours.
- Almost like a book.
- It is.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- It's like reading seven
different books at once.
- That's how they get you, man.
I mean people who play
the same visual novel
over and over again.
And I'm like, what's wrong with you?
- I mean, I did that.(laughing)
- Go outside, go and do
something productive.
Go and play eight hours of
league of legends, be happy.
- I played the clan of
visual novel as well,
just to get to the true ending,
it takes like 200 hours.
- Oh my God.
- But-
- You did that?
- Yeah.
- What's wrong with you?
- Because I was so invested in the story,
because once you get invested,
that's the thing with the secret visual.
- How old were you?
- When I played Konan?
- Yeah.
- Uh, 15.
- How the fuck do you
have the patience for that
as a 15 year old?
Because I used to read
a lot of books anyway.
- Because you find time.
- What do you do as a 15 year old?
- As a 15 year old, like
200 hours means nothing.
- Wow, Halo just came out,
I think for me, like it's..
- I don't wanna to be
like those normy scum
who play Halo.
I wanted to be a different one.
I wanted to embrace my weird bro.
- There's nothing better than
pissing your friends off at school
by like destroying all their (indistinct)
- Yeah, I mean, I would do that at school,
but then I would come home
and be like, you know what,
I miss you Nagi so I wanna know
what happens to you baby girl.
- Okay, I had friends
in my friend group who
we would always play X-Box together,
but there's always that one friend,
we were great friends with,
never hear from him when he goes home.
You were that kid.
- I was that kid.
I was in my room just like
continuously, pressing space bar,
I'm playing Clan ad.
- Huh, Oh my God.
- Because it's so good.
- Check out this gameplay.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Click, click ,click.
- And then after, and then
halfway through Clan ad
I realized the auto function,
so I don't even have to click anything.
I was just, I was just sitting there,
I was like watching a movie.
I was like, Oh, hell yeah, dude, let's go.
- It was just like watching
a movie with extra words.
- I don't think I'd be
able to play a visual novel
like that now though.
- No, no.
- Which is unfortunate.
- Cause it's like watching
anime nowadays, right?
- Right.
- You can't watch an
anime that's over like
13 episodes without
having to fully commit.
- Right, and it's
unfortunate because like,
especially in the last couple of years,
I know there's been some
fucking amazing visual novels
that have come out.
Which I know if I put the
time in, I would fucking love.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- But it's just unfortunate
now that a lot of these,
take like a hundred plus hours,
and I know I would have no time.
- This sounds like hell to me,
this sounds like hell.
- (indistinct) Question to you Connor,
did you not play Doki
Doki when that came out?
- No.
- You missed the Doki Doki.
- I saw it and I was like,
cool girl kills herself.
Everyone's happy about it.
- Doki doki though,
I would recommend because it's
only like five or six hours.
- (indistinct)shorter one, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
It's like a good gateway one.
- When that blew up, I just
had on the tell flashbacks
on YouTube when that blew up(crosstalk).
Cause it was that kind of audience
that was getting attracted to it.
And I'm like, people are
only attracted to this,
cause it's the first time
they're seeing anything
remotely gory, that's it.
- I guarantee it, yeah, exactly.
- I'm sure, there's way
better visual novels
than Doki Doki, right?
- Yeah, oh a hundred percent.
- Right, right, exactly.
- But to them it was like the first time
that they were playing a visual novel
that was also like kind of mind tripping.
And I'm like, you guys clearly
haven't played(indistinct)
because that will fuck you up.
- I was about to say I think like a good,
I dunno a good gateway,
a not good gateway,
visual novel is Son of Utah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because that's the
visual of all that just
hits the ground running.
You know what I mean?
Like it has a really interesting concept,
but it is fucked up.
- It is fucked up.
- So this is a visual novel
written by Guinera Bucci,
who is the same guy who
wrote the in Doka Magica ,
Fate Zero, Psychopaths.
And the concept is about this
guy, I think he wakes up.
- I think he wakes.
- (laughing) I can't
remember the exact beginning,
cause the concept is, there's
just this guy who all he sees,
is just this hellish landscape.
Like it's like grotesque.
Like there are like intestines.
- America.(laughter)
- I'm sorry, I'm gonna get
killed for that.(laughter)
- There's just like intestines
on the walls and just
like veins popping out.
- It's very (indistinct).
- It's like this, it's like a scene
from Silent Hills or something like that.
Some of the most hellish
scenes from silent Hills
and the only thing that's normal
is this like one little Lolly.
That's just like, she's
the only normal thing,
in this hellish landscape.
Cause like every other person is just like
just also hellish blob
that he can't understand.
So the only person that
he can communicate with
is this lolly.
And then that to me just
drew me in immediately.
Right, because it was like,
cause it was like, yeah, what's going on?
Damn, why is it this way?
And like that's what I
look for in a visual novel.
Cause a lot of the problems I see
with a lot of visual
novels, Doki Doki included,
is that the beginning's like very similar,
where she's like, ha,
here's a high school.
- It's a normal setting.
- Here's all the characters.
And you know, it takes
that time to get invested
in the story.
- Right.
- Once you do, it's fucking great.
- Yeah.
- But, Son of Utah if
you can handle a bit,
if you're not squeamish then and you know,
you can handle a bit more, you know
your stomach's a bit stronger.
- If You can get past the gore,
Son of Utah has a fantastic visual novel.
- It's fucking great.
- Like great story, great characters,
everything about it is awesome.
Hey guys, this episode of
the Trash Taste podcast,
is proudly sponsored by CDJapan.
CDJapan is the best place to order
Japanese CDs DVDs
Blu-rays and collectibles.
They offer the widest variety of major
and independent J rock and J-pop music
that you can find anywhere.
- [Connor] Not only are
they an E-commerce site,
they also have a proxy shipping service
that is easily the most popular offer.
- So basically to explain proxy shipping
if there's certain items
that you can only get,
if you're in Japan, like for example,
we recently bought a lot of Jojo merge
that you could only get in Japan.
Do you want to explain what
you've bought from Japan?
- I mean, we have the
watch that Joey's wear.
- Hell yeah.
- Let's say if you wanted
those sweet Jojo suits
that I posted on my Twitter,
couldn't get that unless
you live in Japan.
But if there was a proxy service,
you'd be able to get a hold of those.
- Yeah, so all you need to
do is give them the link
to whatever products you
want and they will buy it,
and ship it for you straight
to wherever you live.
- And the good thing is in case
you didn't get any of that,
then on the website as well,
they give you a step-by-step guide,
on how proxy services work.
So you fully understand how to
get the necessary equipment,
and much that you're looking for.
- So basically if you see anything
on our shelves that you can find online,
that might not be
available on that website,
then you can use the
proxy shipping service.
- We've also heard that
their customer service
is extraordinary and
it's one of the aspects
that they care most about of the service.
- And of course, with the recent events
that have been going on in the world,
they've also done a really
good job to keep everything
up to date for all of the customers,
including all their social media,
and of course the
affirmation Customer service.
So you can be sure that you're
in some pretty good hands.
- There's tons of different
delivery methods on the website,
such as DHL, FedEx.
So no matter what you
ordered, you can guarantee
that you will get it
safely and in one piece.
- And no matter where you live as well,
they will make sure your item gets to you.
- Let's see what Jojo stuff they got.
- I mean, just on the side,
Oh, they have the journo pen.
- Oh yeah, they do, look at that.
- Me and Connor have a..
- Yeah, I have this one, I
also have like three knockoffs.
- Oh wait, no, I have the
(indistinct) pen, actually.
- I have the drummer one.
- It's really cool.
It works as a figurine
and it works as a pen.
- You would never wanna use it.
- You'd never use it as a pen.
- It's an awkward pen to use.
- Yeah, imagine buying
this and being like,
I'm gonna use this.
- But it is cool, it is cool.
- If you want something like that,
it's available on CD Japan.
- Oh, you can get the entirety
of the market in Japanese.
- Oh Stardust crusaders.
- 20 bucks?
for the entirety of
Stardust crusaders, bro.
This is why you need to learn
Japanese so you can buy manga,
Japanese and read it for that cheap.
- That's fucking crazy.
- You can hear the first volume
of steel ball run for $6.
- $6.
- Oh my God, that's so Cool.
- Let's see what figures they have.
- Dead alive.
- Oh yeah, (indistinct)
China dress version.
Oh that looks fucking nice
though, look at that dude.
- That's hot, that's hot.
- That's hot.
- That's a lot of damage.
Look at that, the
important part right there.
Hell yeah, what else they got?
- Is that coggy or summer?
- I saw that actually.
- Yeah, wait, enhance, enhance.
- Enhance.
- Dammit where did it go?
- We lost, we lost it.
- We lost her, where did she go?
So again, if you want to go
and check it got some Japan only stuff
that you might not be able
to get from your country.
Then CD japan.com is the
best place to get it.
So again, thank you to CD Japan,
for sponsoring today's
episode back to the video.
- Okay. I'm hearing more about
these great visual novels,
and they sound crazy, but I don't know
if I'm just a person who's never gonna get
into visual novels cause of how I am.
Like is, is Dangan Ronpa a visual novel?
Cause I felt like it was.
- Yeah, okay.
- Cause that shit dragged on.
- Dungan Runpa, is kind
of half visual novel,
half history game.
Because it's visual novel in the aspect of
when your going through
the story elements,
it's a hundred percent visual novel.
Like in the way it looks and
the way it presents the story.
But when it comes to the
actual mode of mysteries
you have to solve
there's a bit of exploration that happens.
And the whole part of when
you go to the actual trial
that's a whole game in and of itself.
- Yeah, that's true.
I mean, I just got remembering
being so frustrated
playing that.
I don't know why.
- Which one did you play though?
- The first one.
- Okay, don't play the first one.
- Is it bad?
- The second one is by far the best.
- I thought everyone said like
the third one's the worst.
- The third one is the worst.
- First one ain't great either.
- I didn't, I wasn't a huge
fan, I played all three.
First one was okay.
The second one though is by far
the most optimized the best,
in terms of like game playings,
of the story in terms of
characters, everything.
And then the third one,
they just dropped the ball.
They are all so disappointing.
- (chuckling)No.
- They bombed that so fucking hard.
It was the ending to the third
one, which I was just like,
it made me sit through three
whole games of this shit,
and that's how you end it?
Fuck you.
- If you had to like pitch it to me,
to get me into visual novels,
I'm sure there are some viewers at home.
How would you do that?
Cause like, as somebody who's
never experienced visual novel
and doesn't really think
that he'll like it.
- I mean, do you like books?
- Hmm, it's been a while
since I have read a book.
- (laughing) Well there's
our first problem.
- (indistinct) with books is
that I never seek them out,
but every time I've read a
book, I've had a great time.
- Yeah, I get it.
Then that might just be
the case with visual novels
or maybe all you need is
just that one visual novel
that you can relate to.
And because you know the pool
of visual novels is so deep.
- What's like some
beginner recommendations
for visual novels that like everyone must?
- Honestly Doki Doki.
- Really?
- Yeah, Doki Doki is a great,
like it's just a great starter
one because it's so short.
If you can get through like,
the worst part Doki Doki unfortunately,
is like the first half where it's just
setting up the scene and everything.
But like at the halfway
point hits and it's like,
Oh this has got a lot
of interesting ideas.
- In defense of Doki Doki though,
the reason why the first
half is so boring is because,
it's parodying visual novels.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So knowing that if you go into Doki Doki
with that mindset, then the first half is
a little more bearable.
But the thing is, if you're
not interested in the actual,
the problem with visual novels is,
if you're not invested in the story,
you're not gonna enjoy it.
No matter how flashy or good it is, right?
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- And that's the unfortunate thing is that
so many visual novels
get passed under the rug
because too many people are just too lazy
to get into the story.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- This guy.
- Yeah, this guy.
- I hate story in video games.
- Okay, here's the question to you then?
What are like some
visual novel adaptations
for animate that you've
just really enjoyed.
- That's a good question.
Have you watched a lot?
- Oh, I think I have.
- Maybe you have watched a
lot and you just didn't know.
- I can't remember the top
of my head, which ones?
- Some of them might be Stein's Gates.
- I like Stein's gate a lot,
but that felt like a visual
novel when I was watching that,
you know what I mean?
There's lots of moments where
they weren't afraid to
like be boring.(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Not be boring,
but they weren't afraid to let you sit
with (indistinct) situations.
- It's a very slow character
development matter.
- Amazing animator.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like I fucking loved that.
- And it's an amazing visual novel.
- Yeah, cause I remember I
had the game on three 60.
I just never played it.
- Right, right, right.
- I've don't know why I never played it.
I think I bought, I watched
the anime and thought,
wow, I wanna play this.
I bought it, never played it,
cause I was like, what a muffet.(laughter)
- There's also like the
Fate franchise love those.
- Fate, every Fate series I've watched,
I didn't watch the new ones
cause they were based on..
- I mean, that's a lot of Fate series.
- Heaven's Feel.
- Heaven Feel, I didn't
watch Heaven's Feel.
I watched, I love Fate
Stay Night and Fate zero,
are some of my favorite
oh Unlimited Blade works,
some of my favorite.
- Oh that's all just the Fate game.
- Oh I know it is.
But then, you know,
you wanna get into Fate
and you see the fucking
chart of like the Fate law.
And you're like, wait,
there's how many Sabers?
I don't want this many Sabers.
- It was just Type Moon being like,
let's make this universe just
so difficult to get into.
- So you watch the anime and you think,
this is a little confusing, but
it makes sense, I like this.
And then you actually go
and look what Fate is,
and you're like, this is a dumpster fire.
- I feel like the biggest enemy
against people getting
into fate is ironically,
the Fate fandom itself.
- [Joey] Oh no.
- Because, here's the thing, I'm like,
I have one of like one of
the most popular Fate videos,
which is just me parodying, how to
unlike a newcomer trying to
understand the Fate series.
- Yeah.
- And like to me, as someone
who like really likes Fate,
it's really not that hard to get into.
You've watched Unlimited Blade Works.
You've watched Fate zero.
It doesn't matter which
one, which either one.
- They are both amazing.
- Yeah, yeah, they can
be enjoyed by themselves,
and then from there, you
just take it from there.
- (indistinct) told me when I was trying
to get into the fate
series, I was like, okay,
I can trust your opinion
because you've been with Fate
from the very beginning until now.
How do I get into it?
And he was just like, watch Fate zero,
watch Fate unlimited blade wars.
And you will understand 95% of the law,
and the rest is just a bonus.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- But the problem is
the like the Fate fandom
as a collective, just can't
seem to fucking agree on it
because there's like, I fucking lost it
because there was this
Reddit thread recently,
on like our anime and someone had made,
I think the title of the thread was,
"I made an easy to follow guide
on how to get into Fates."
Right?(laughter)
- The ultimate click play.
- And I fucking burst out
laughing when I saw like,
800 odd votes, 700 comments.
And I'm just like, Oh
boy, here we fucking go.
- That ratio, oh my God.
- I'm gonna get the fucking popcorn.
And I remember like one of the
top comments were just like,
Oh yeah just watch Fate Zero,
it doesn't really fucking matter.
Fate Zero is good.
And like, the next comment is,
but you're not gonna answer
an X if you watch Fate Zero.
I'm not just like, Oh my God.
Like how is how I can't imagine
how it looks for a newcomer,
cause it looks like a (indistinct) right?
- Yeah.
- It does, I mean, I
watched Fate Zero first
and I thought it was
like a classic, right?
I thought it's a great show.
I mean, I can re watch Fate Zero.
- Yeah.
- I don't know, do you
get put off by shows,
if the fan base is
toxic or shit like that?
Cause I don't, and I'm just like fuck you,
I'm gonna watch the show
and make my own opinion.
- Yeah, it's weird, right?
Because I remember the Fate Fandom,
used to be a lot more toxic, right?
- It used to be more toxic?
- Oh no, definitely there
was this phase, right?
Where if you recommended
people to start Fate,
with Fate zero, when that first came out,
then there will be
people in the Fate fandom
who were just like, how dare you?
How dare you not just recommend
the original visual novels?
Like he was like, if you're
not willing to sit through
a two hundred hour visual novel,
then why are you even
enjoying this franchise?
- O my God.
- You know what I mean?
And now it's evolved
a bit, now, it's like,
okay, people just want other
people to get into Fate.
But now they just don't know how to agree
on one specific ways to get into Fate.
And it's the problem because
it's a problem of fate
being a visual novel adaptation.
Because there is no perfect
adaptation of Fate Stay Night,
cause if you think about it logically,
if you think about something
like the Montgomery series,
easy, you start with
release order, all right.
So you start with
(indistinct) cause that came
out first, you know.
But the problem with fate
is that chronologically,
the first released adaptation
of the Fate franchise,
is just shit, right?
Cause it was..
(crosstalk)
Yeah Fate stay night adapted
by Studio Dean, right?
- Yeah.
- So that basically
adapted the first roots of
the Fate visual novel, the
Face Stay Night visual novel,
Right?
But it's also like a
really hard starting point
for newbies to get into
fate because it's just shit.
Its not recommended in this day and age.
So what you would have
to recommend is probably
unlimited blade works,
which is the second routes.
But then, you know but
then people skip over the
like entire first root which
is the Fate Stay Night route.
So it's complicated because of the way
the visual novel is laid out.
- I hope, I genuinely
thought Fate Stay Night
and Fate Stay Unlimited
Blade works was just a remake
of Fate Stay Night.
- Yeah, you think so, right?
- Is it not?
- No, no, no.
- It's completely different?
- I think from my understanding,
correct me if I'm wrong.
- Okay.
- Fate Stay Night Unlimited
Blade Works and Heaven's Feel
are just different endings
to Fate Stay Night.
- Yeah, okay so..
- I feel like this is how NASA must feel,
trying to fucking program their rockets.
- And people keep saying
that the Montgomery series
is complicated, like.
- No, no, no.
So yeah, there were like three
routes in the original Fate.
Oh my God, I'm doing the meme now.
- This is the short version.
- What happened to numbers?
We can't number shit anymore?
- It's because of the way
visual novels was laid out
with different routes, all right?
- Yeah.
- So you think of something
like Clan ad or something,
where like a different route,
you get a different girl
or like, you know, that's..
- Like a Pokemon, women are
like Pokemon collect them.
- So in Fate it's like every
route is completely different,
but it starts at the same starting point,
if that makes sense.
So technically..
- Do I need a notepad, like,
do I need to like write this shit down?
- They all start at the
same starting point,
but that's not made apparent
in the anime adaptations.
- No, no.
- I fucking hate(indistinct)
- Which is why you would think
that Unlimited Blade Wars
and Fate Stay Night
and Fate zero and Heaven's Feel,
are completely different games.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- But in retrospect they all are the same.
- Dude, sometimes I feel
like I'm the only asshole,
who just doesn't give a
fuck about half the shit.
Cause like everyone seems to know
and then I'm sitting there like,
I just wanna just click play.
- Oh trust me, it took me
fucking forever to understand 1%.
- Most people like me or
like you guys, I don't know.
I feel I'm in the minority.
- I've been here since the beginning.
So you guys probably don't remember
that there's been two unlimited
blade works adaptations.
- I did not know that.
Wait, wait both by(indistinct)?
- No one like Studio
Dean did Fate Stay Night,
then I think they did Unlimited
Blade Works movie as well.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, yeah.
And then (indistinct)
came along and was like,
fuck that shit we are
starting over at Fate Zero.
And then they were like, okay fuck, okay,
we've done Fate Zero,
fuck Fate Stay Night.
Let's go to Unlimited Blade Work,
and then adapt Heaven's feel.
- Cause I only remember
that there was only
two Fate Stay Nights.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- And then there was the
Studio Dean Fate Stay Night.
- This is too much.
- And then, (indistinct)
was like, hold my beer,
let's do a better adaptation.
And then it was just all from there.
But I didn't know about
the second unlimited one.
- Yeah, and this is just a making fail,
it's so fucking bad now.
- It is.
- And we are not even
mentioning all the(indistinct).
- This is just the main
timeline, Kanon as well.
- Just watch Fate Zero, and
then if you like it(crosstalk).
- Honestly, from what I've heard,
if you wanna get into fate,
just watch Fate Zero and
Unlimited Blade Works.
- Fate Zero is a great fucking show,
and it's, you can just
watch it on its own.
You don't need to have a college degree,
or a PhD to understand
what the fuck is going on.
Just watch it.
If you like all the characters, you know?
It's fucking great.
Hey, watch Montgomery it's
less complicated.(laughter)
- Yeah, so is Pokemon, like
what are we recommending there?
- Fate's a lot of fun.
I mean, you get into
it for the good story,
and then you're like, man.
- I got into it cause I
was doing a fandub of it.
- Oh seriously?
- (indistinct) someone
else's fandub of it.
- Oh, okay.
- I think I was playing like.
- How the hell do you do an
abridge of the Fate series?
- It wasn't abridged, it was a fandub.
- I know, but like just
the hypothetical question.
Has anyone done it?(indistinct)
(crosstalk)
how do you abridge
something that complicated?
- I mean, you can just
abridge a certain show,
but like having to explain
the entire franchise,
I mean, that's an undertaking.
- I want a Fate abridged
where the entire bridge is
just them explaining the Fate law.
- And I'm actually doing
a video on that, spoilers.
- Oh really?
Great minds think alike,
big brain boys think alike.
- I've actually been working
on that for like over a month.
- Of course you have.
- That was not a scripted bit,
I'm just letting you know.
- Got promoting his future content.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's probably not going to be out,
by the time this like
this episode comes out.
But I don't know, it's there's different.
Cause the Fate franchise
is so wide, right?
But it's like just this rabbit hole,
that you can just sink in
and there will always be..
- I feel like we found a
trap talking about it here.
- Yeah, yeah exactly.
- But that's the thing like,
if you just wanna enjoy Fate Zero
and Unlimited Blade Works, you can just..
- That's what I did.
- Yeah, what did you think of them?
- I loved them both individually.
I felt very satisfied and I felt that,
I'm okay not having more.
Like I was, I saw the,
it's like you finish it,
and then you walk outside,
and you see the rest of the world on fire.
And you're like, no, not today.
- Are you gonna watch Heaven's Feel then?
- I thought someone told me that, that
was just based on the Gacha game.
- No, that's Fate Grand Order.
- That's Fate Grand Order.
- Oh, is that an anime series as well?
- Yeah, there's a Fate Grand Order anime.
(crosstalk)
- To to make it more confusing,
the Fate Grand Order anime
adapts the like the, like
one of the later chapters
in the Fate Grand Order Gacha games.
So it doesn't even start at the beginning.
- Why, are they doing this?
- Ask Type moon dude.
- Like I wanna watch more
cause I enjoyed what I watched,
but at the same time
it just seems like I'm gonna
be watching it, thinking...
- That's the thing it's like,
I'm scared to start watching
the Heaven's feel movies,
as much as I want to
because I'm just like,
oh God, do I have to like fucking revise?
- I'm gonna be paranoid.
I'm gonna be watching
thinking like, (indistinct)
I just wanted to like,
watch something, you know?
- It's very daunting,
but it's really not that
complicated because..
(laughter)
- You say that.
- You literally wrote
a 10-minute rant about
how much of a fucking mess this is.
What do you mean, it's
not that complicated?
- Look, you can enjoy Heaven's
Feel if you've like watched,
Fate Zero and UBW that's
the end(indistinct)
- You control a lot of things(indistinct)
- You know he's a veteran,
when he calls Unlimited Blade Wars
UBW, it's like it's too long.
UBW, you know what I mean, right?
- He (indistinct) so much
in his daily vocabulary,
but he has to shorten
Unlimited Blade Works to UBW.
- Fellow Fate fans, I tried, okay?
I tried my fucking hardest.
- If I find that..
- I'm not falling for your
trap today(indistinct),
not today.
I'm happy not having(indistinct)
- I will sing that time
into a visual novel,
before I try and get into the Fate soon.
- Okay, do people just
like not watch shows,
and then just think, okay, I'm done.
I've had enough of this show.
That's how I felt with Fate.
- Well yeah, I mean, some
people just get so invested
in the characters that they
just wanna go further beyond.
- Like Who liked Saber so much
that we had this many Sabers.
Why, wasn't one Saber okay?
Am I mistaken with being
happy with one Saber ?
- I don't know, man.
You should ask his people.
- Okay, okay.
- What's wrong with with one Saber.
(crosstalk).
Why is one Saber not enough?
- Okay, okay, here's the thing, right?
I didn't get it until I started
playing Fate Grand Order,
and then I totally get it.
Cause I like, I don't
care too much about Saber,
but Rin, Rin's my girl, so.
- Oh, I know(crosstalk)
- So whenever like there's..
- How many Rins are there?
- I mean, there's, there's no.(laughter)
- The fact that there's no clear answer
to this question is fucked up.
- There's not as many
Rins as there are Sabers.
- What do you mean?
There shouldn't be more than one.
- For example, like
getting Ishta, for example,
I'm like, I need to get,
every time there's a character
that kind of resembles Rin, I'm like,
well time to(indistinct)
- I'm not going to lie,
the first time I saw Ishta,
I was like, Oh, is that Rin?
- You know, I hear this shit,
and all I think of like
man, this sounds like,
it's nearing Kingdom
Hearts level of bullshit.
- Oh no.
- Oh, no, Kingdom Heart wishes,
it could be that awkward.
- we're just talking about the series,
we haven't gotten into Fate law.
- We're not getting into that.(laughter)
(crosstalk)
- Apocrypha and like
(indistinct) and stuff like that.
- You know, being around anime fans,
you hear these words
like Apocrypha whatever.
I hate that shit so much,
I don't know what it means.
I don't wanna know what it means.
- I don't know what it means either.
- I hate it
- But I know it's just a spinoff.
- I hear it so much, right?
- All I know is that
Apocrypha and (indistinct)
are spin offs but the spinoffs
that also add to the law.
- It's time to stop.
- I mean.(laughing)
- No, we are not getting into this.
- Okay, So to start off my
lecture today on Fate law.
- (indistinct)things
that I didn't get before,
let's go back to that.
(laughter)Oh my God.
You have two minutes gone, say your piece.
- Okay, just watch Fate Zero.
Watch Unlimited Blade Works,
and then that's like
the main line timeline.
So you can enjoy Heaven's Feel.
And then if you wanna enjoy
more of the Fate franchise,
you can because none of
it's technically Kanon
even though it is, but I'm
not going to get into that.
Just watch the main timeline
shows and that's me, that's it.
- You say watch the main timeline shows,
but at this point we don't know
what the main time line shows are.
- I'm convinced people that like fate,
also like cock and bull torture.(laughter)
They wanna die.
- The one thing about Fate
that I wanna say is that,
I couldn't fucking believe when,
I asked the same question
to Nobi, my friend,
who's like heavily into Fate about Saber.
I was like, why there's so many Sabers?
And do you know what he said to me?
He's like Saber, the clause
or Saber the character?
(laughter)
and I mean, what do you mean?
I mean, Saber and he's
like, yeah, which one?
I'm like, what do you mean which one?
Cause there's Saber the clause,
and then there's the character, Saber.
- I know that, I know that, I know that.
Cause like she is the Saber clause
- Yeah, yeah.(crosstalk)
- But then yeah, but then he was like,
Saber clause, Saber
character, I'm like, Saber.
The one called Saber.
Which one is it?
And at that point I was like, okay
I don't think I'll ever be able
to get into this franchise.
So bottom line,
when it comes to visual
novels, maybe skip out on Fate.
- I'm convinced, right?
If Fate didn't exist,
the world would be 100% more productive.
We would have cured every
known disease on the planet.
But these people are too busy
making fucking timeline charts.
- Yeah, Type moon would actually be like
a cancer institute, right?
- Honestly, if we redirected
that, that mental resource
into doing something productive,
there would be no poverty,
poverty would be ended.
But instead we wanted a hundred Sabers.
That's what we went for.
- It's because we just wanted
to collect the waifus, okay?
We just want a slightly
different variation
of the same character,
so they could like sell us
to like roll another like
1,000 rolls in the Gacha.
And then we can be like,
yeah, I have another Saber.
I have everything I want.
Oh wait, they released another Saber?
Oh, okay, okay I see, I see.
- This is just like that, you know
like that there's memes
where it's like the fucking,
the business meeting with the
executives and they're like,
what do the people want?
They really like, it seems like gentlemen,
they really enjoy Saber.
And then someone's like
Saber two, Saber two
and it's like three Sabers
- Saber two, but it's not the Saber.
- If saber is so good, why
isn't there a Saber two?
The executives are like,
we got your back.
- Super Saber, you want a super Saber?
- Saber black.(laughing)
Saber pink.
- There's actually like a red Saber.
- Oh no, I'm done.
- Oh, red Saber and the Saber red.
- No, no, there's a red
Saber and Saber of red.
Those are two different characters.
- At this point Time Moon
has to be fucking with us.
Right, like I'm ready for them.
I'm ready for Time moon to just come out
and just like
pulling(indistinct)just being like,
yeah all of that, has no meaning.
We just wanted to fuck with you.
- I'm going insane, listening to Gon,
try and explain this shit
to me, I hate this so much.
- I wanna have an
episode where I just like
spend an hour explaining Fate
law to you guys. (indistinct)
(laughter)
- But going back to visual novels, right?
That we would recommend to
beginners, AKA, not fucking..
- It's like one pain to another, man.
- Other than Doki Doki literature club,
what's like another visual novel
that you would recommend to Conner?
- Undertale.
- I don't know because..
- There are none, psych.
- Okay, question, would you
recommend kinda of a show Jo?
- Kind of a Show Jo also
has like, acts one, is
it takes reading through act
one to get really invested
into kind of a show Jo, kind of a show Jo
is great by the way.
- Is there like 10 million
Sabers in that as well?
- (laughing) There isn't,
70 cuddlers unfortunately.
- Kind of a Show Jo Actually has a very,
very interesting backstory.
(crosstalk)
Cause I mean, I feel like the backstory
is almost as interesting
as the visual novel itself.
I don't wanna say too much,
cause I'm also working on a video on it,
but it's a visual novel
that basically originated from Four Chan.
- Can you believe something good
actually came out of For Chan once?
- No, no, no.
So it's like a data simulator
with crippled girls,
from Four Chan.
And you say that and you're like, wow.
- (indistinct)Be quaking.
- But like it's, it's one of
the most like wholesome kind
of inspirational stories
about how these disabled girls
like really just, are just
normal people and just like,
like how they deal with
their disabilities.
- That sounds good, I'd read that.
- Yeah, it's great.
- It's fantastic.
- It's, actually a really,
really good visual novel.
And if like how much
patience do you have though?
Cause I've seen you gaming, right?
If you're not doing something
within the first five seconds,
if you're not like head shotting.
(crosstalk)
- No scope in the first 10 seconds.
- I have an amount that I
can like power up in myself.
- But is it enough to go through
the first chapter of catalog show jo?
- Why is it that bad?
- It's not bad.
(crosstalk)
- How long is the first chapter?
- Oh, that's a good question.
- I can't remember.
- Depends how fast you read.
- I'd say like an hour or two.
- That's a lot of time.
- An hour or two maybe?
- Yeah.
- Holy shit.
- That's the same with Doki Doki,
cause like it takes an hour or two
to get through the first half.
- But, mind you unlike Doki Doki,
which is about a six to seven hour game,
cuddler show Jo has about 30 to 40 hours.
- That's fine.
- So compared to that,
an hour's not too bad, until it starts.
- Honestly, I do think Son
of Utah would be really
really good for someone like you.
Cause I know you can handle that shit.
And that was something
that hooked me instantly.
- Maybe I'll stream, am
I allowed to stream it?
Is it a game I can stream?
- No, it's It's been on Twitch.
- Oh geez, goddammit Twitch.
- It was the first visual novel
that was banned on Twitch,
because of course(indistinct)
be out here just being like,
I'm not making anything
that's family friendly.
I'm here to traumatize
everybody that plays my shit.
- No, cause it's a story,
it's a visual novel that
doesn't have that, you know, entry period.
It has a very interesting concept,
and it just kind of hooks you right away.
And for me, I remember
just reading Son of Utah,
and I read it all in like one sitting,
cause I just wanted to know
immediately what happens next.
Like there was no break from
me starting it to finishing it.
In terms of like visual novel type games.
I don't know, like, okay.
Here's the thing,
would you count the persona series,
as like a visual novel with
a lot of gameplay in it?
- Oh, that seems like an RPG to me.
- Okay, the thing with
the persona series is that
it's really interesting
because yes, it is a JRPG
but a whole lot of the JRPG element,
and like how you play the
JRPG element on that game,
is dependent on the visual
novel side of the game.
- Yeah.
- Because what the persona series did,
which I think is fucking genius is that,
they made you the way
that they made you sit
through the story of persona,
and it's a long story,
if you've played any persona game, right?
the genius way that they
made you sit through,
is that by sitting through it,
and physically interacting
with certain characters
in certain ways it changes
how strong you become
in the JRPG element.
- Yeah.
- So what you do is you
form Alison persona five.
What you do, is you
by talking to certain
characters and befriending them,
and like going out to do these
like normal everyday things,
you would level up your
different abilities.
And those abilities then
get directly reflected
in the JRPG element.
So the more you're involved in the story,
the easier time you will
have in the JPG elements.
And what that forced you to do
is that not only is it
interesting because it's like
you're playing two
different games at once,
but you are literally forced
to sit through the story.
- Yeah.
- So everybody that plays
it enjoys the story..
- So like, if you imagine
like a Gacha game right?
- Yeah.
- So in every Gacha game there's like,
the gameplay element and then
there's the Gacha element.
- I played Fire Emblem, Three Houses.
- Right.
- And that had a lot of story-building,
which I found so boring.
- Oh, you found that boring.
- Yeah, I found it really boring.
I would just skip, whenever
they start talking,
I'm like B B B.
- But the thing is fire
emblem, three houses
kind of did the same thing where,
you are doing everyday
things around the campus
would affect you in battle.
- I mean, I liked Fire
Emblem Three Houses, right?
I enjoyed what I did, but
I, for whatever reason man,
the moment I see text pop
up on my screen, I'm like,
you are in the way of my game.
- You are so monkey minded.
- You got that monkey vibe.(laughing)
- I don't know what
happened to me in the womb,
but like, I can't pay
attention to story in games.
And I'm sure there's one
or two people out there,
who can sympathize with me,
but the moment story
comes on any video game,
I'm like, where's the skip button?
Where's it?
- Really?
- I can't, I can't pay attention.
- So what's what's your favorite
story in a video game then?
(laughter)
- Trick question.
- Has there ever been one?
- Bro, I need to like
really go deep in my memory.
I remember the only game that
I think I watched the cut scenes.
And I think I was like 15.
I don't even know why I played this game.
It's called blue dragon it's a JLPG.
Weird games, stupid
people in the comments,
were like, I don't know
what that is, it's a JLPG
- Comment below, if
you've played blue dragon.
- It just seemed like a
dragon quest knockoff.
But I didn't know what
dragon quest was at the time
but I watched dragon quest
afterwards and I was like,
wait a second.
This looks awfully like
that game I used to like.
And you know, it pains
me every time, right?
When I go to press that skip button like,
I don't know what it is.
Like, is there something wrong with me,
that I can't enjoy story and video games.
(crosstalk)
Maybe, but like for me, it's like,
I look for a gameplay loop, not a story.
I'm like the complete opposite of you.
- Yeah.
- Well no, cause you play,
you've played league of legends,
you played at fair amount.
You are playing Valorant right now.
- In terms of like single player games.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Like, I need a story.
- I don't play single player games.
- I mean, you played for example Cup heads
or something like that.
- Cup heads yeah I should
speak on Cup heads.
That was fun, but that's
for the gameplay loop.
- Yeah, exactly.
Like I tried playing Cup head.
I'm like why am I playing cup head?
What is the narrative reason
for me to complete this game?
- I just love running gun games.
- I need a narrative reason,
and if you need me to sit through
like a two hour cut scene,
I'll fucking do it.
If it's a good story, I'll fucking do it.
- Like the reason I loved
doom 2016 so much is
you literally start that game.
You smash a skull open and
you start shooting.(laughing)
That was like, Oh my goodness.
- June 2016 is the epitome
of like(indistinct)
(crosstalk)
- They made a game for me.
- It was like, gun,
enemy, shoot, let's go.
- That was like exactly what I wanted.
I just wanted the game that
was like fuck the story.
Let's just make a gameplay
that is addictive, right?
And so when I play, like,
you know what pisses me
off to death about JLPGs.
I love JLPGs.
- Do you?
- But the moment, they
start making the menu
a fucking challenge is when I start,
I'm like this is too much, like,
I love Fire Emblem Three Houses, right.
But there was times in that,
the menuing was like half the game play.
- I'm the officer now.
- Yeah, yes.
- When there's a complex menu, I was like
Oh man, look at all the
different things I can do.
- Let me play the damn game.
- You are playing the
game on the main menu.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- Okay, you know, like I go
from, I jump from multiplayer
games to multiplayer games
like, I've been like diamond
in league of legends
like five years in a row.
I started playing TFT
recently got to diamond one.
And that nilly master tier, if you know
if you play these games,
you know, it's good shit.
I'm a big brain essentially
playing Valorant now with gone.
Sometimes it's a good game to CSK.
I played Overwatch, got to master in that.
- Okay, what's like your opinion on like,
something like the
metal gear solid series.
(crosstalk)
- Yeah I played(indistinct)
- Well that's because that's
like very heavily stolen.
- That's like a that's
not visual(indistinct)
(laughter)
- Like Halo, I love Halo.
I have no idea what any
of the stories are about.
I remember like...
- The halo story is great.
- Yeah, I remember there was a scene.
- Did you play Master Flex?
- No, no, no, not too much story for me.
I remember Halo, right?
I remember they like hyped
it up the (indistinct)
I mean, if you don't know
the Cortana, you know
but she comes back, sort of.
Cortana dies, right.
I remember everyone was
hyping up. so sad, so sad.
And I was playing my friend
and we are doing it together.
And the moment the cut scene
happened, I fucking skipped it.
No, no, what are you doing?
We need to find out what happened.
I'm like why?
we gotta shoot things.
- Oh, this is hurting me so much.
- I don't know man, I
just, I'm sure there's one.
I'm I in the minority here?
- I don't know.
- I feel like it's 50, 50, right?
- Maybe.
- Or like 70 30, cause
there must be a reason why
the most popular games are
like multiplayer games, right?
- Yeah, because they're played
by 11 year olds, you know.
- Monkey brain.
- That monkey brain.
- I mean the reason I got into
games like league environ is
just cause I could just get into it.
It's like, it was like a stress reliever.
- It's a 40 minute thing that
you do, and it's no more.
- It's just like a,
it's like a different
kind of stress relief
and like animal crossing, for example,
but you just get in a
quick session, you get out,
you play as long as you
want and then you get out.
- It's a closed loop,
you don't feel like there's anything else.
- For like single-player experiences.
I like to get invested in the game,
in the same way that I like
to get invested in anatomy.
And like, I love just, I
love that feeling of just,
marathoning a show and just getting..
- Putting yourself into a story,
and being able to like physically
interact with the story.
It's like, it's so fucking cool.
- I think I ruined games
for myself during the X-box.
- So is there literally not a single game
that you enjoyed the story of?
- I cannot, like I enjoyed
Zelda Breath of the wild
a fuck ton, but I don't
know like what I was doing.
I just remember, cause when I..
- Breath of the wild is
such a good story too.
- Is it?
The moment we started talking (indistinct)
I'm like, give me the bomb,
give me the items, shut the fuck up.
I need a(indistinct)
because breath of wild
was the last game I
played where I got like,
no matter what other game was out there,
that I wanna play it, like
you said, it sucked me in.
I loved that game.
- Yeah.
- That was because I felt like
the way they built the world
didn't require a story,
cause the story is the
same shit we're used to.
(crosstalk)
- In my opinion, the most genius thing,
about breath of the wild is that yes,
you could skip all of the dialogue
and still really fucking enjoy it purely.
- That's why I loved it.
Cause it was like, do your own thing.
- It's even more enjoyable
when you actually
talk to the MPCs and
especially the ones that are
kind of just out in the open,
not the ones that are in the towns,
and just hearing what they say.
It does such a good job at world-building
I'm serious, you're laughing,
but the MPCs, like I
listened to all the MPCs
and I'm like, okay I have so
much of a better understanding
of this world now.
- (indistinct) He's like I'm
on the visual novel place.
- Yeah, exactly.(laughter)
- I'm hearing this and I'm like,
wait, you spoke to the MPCs?
- Yeah.
- Wait like, okay.
The thing I hate the most, right?
Is when games make you speak
to MPCs, I hate that so much.
- It depends on like the game for me,
because if it's a world
I'm not invested in,
then I'm like, whatever, this is shitty.
But if it's like, where I'm
super invested in, I speak,
I'm the kind of person
just speaks to everyone,
cause I wanna get as much content
as I can out of this game.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And I remember speaking
to you and you were like,
I can't enjoy a game
if I'm not making someone
else's day be worse.(laughter)
- Okay, okay.
I said that to you as a joke,
but that's kind of true.
This is something that like to me,
and I, maybe this is, again,
coming back to the episode
where we spoke about chess, right?
Like to me, gaming has
always been a thing of like,
it's like a thing where I
can, I can learn a skill.
I can get better at that skill,
and then I can beat others, right?
And like, you know,
sometimes you play a game
of league of legends,
and it feels like you
are playing the piano.
Like, it feels like
you're just crushing them.
But then when you get, when you lose,
it's not a good feeling.(laughter)
I wanna play a game,
and I wanna beat other people off the top.
- He wants to make
someone else's day worse.
That's how he gets enjoyment.
- Like, its why like if
I play league of legends,
I can't play normal games.
Like, I need to play a ranked game,
cause I know that people will give a shit.
Cause if people are giving a
shit, no one's invested, right?
If I fucking die a ton, no
one gives a shit in a normal,
I mean, they do, but I don't give a shit.
- Yeah.
- But if I die in a ranked
game, I'm like, fuck.
- I think that's why I'd
never gone into PVP games.
- Really?
- it's because I've never given a shit.
- Really.
- Yeah.
- That's pretty wild.
- Like I can't like, I don't
give a fuck if I'm playing.
- Do you know like refining a skill,
like getting good at something and like.
- That's not what I play games for.
- I mean, that's what I do.
- I play games for fucking escapism.
- Right, but then I guess
my form of escapism is
learning the skill and
having that gameplay loop
of doing it over and over again,
and then going against other people.
- No, I don't know of that,
because I don't give it.
Cause like, in my opinion,
the reason why I love JLPGs,
is because there are no
bragging rights with JLPGs.
By finishing a JLPG, it's not
like, yeah, I beat this game.
Like, that's why I beat
persona five like five times.
Not because I wanted to brag to people
that I beat it five times,
but because I wanted to see
the route of all the waifus.
- But you just bragged
about it, I'm joking.
- Yeah, I just did it, but..
- No, it's not for bragging rights.
I don't do it for that.
And I don't do it to feel
superior or anything.
I just do it cause to me,
I guess, gaming for me,
the way that it's been an escape is that,
I get to sink myself.
Cause I need to be challenged constantly.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- And when a game doesn't challenge me,
in like either mechanical
skill or like mentally,
like I'm just not invested,
cause I'm like it's not challenging me.
I need something to challenge me.
- I mean, this is why I like
playing instruments, right?
So that I could get that
side of my brain focused.
- But then I guess, we
are all different, right?
Like for me, I think maybe escapism,
and you do have that part of
you want to challenge yourself,
but it's satisfied by just
learning an instrument
or playing an instrument.
But for me, it's like I think
it's way too consuming for me.
Like I'm way too competitive.
Like I was that one asshole in school,
who turned everything into
the Olympics.(laughter)
- There was always that one guy.
- I was like, oh, we're doing a light jog?
Oh, we are doing a light jog all right.
And then I would fucking sprint, right?
- Yeah.
- I remember like I can,
if this doesn't explain
how like competitive I am,
I don't know what will.
In school, when we used to
do long distance running,
I was terrible at long distance running.
- [Gigguk] Okay.
- But you bet every single time we did it,
I made myself throw up, I
was so desperate.(laughter)
I was so desperate to win
the long distance running,
that I would literally,
every single time we ran
I would push myself into the point
of throwing up because I wouldn't stop,
I wouldn't stop, right.
- He don't miss.(laughter)
- And I remember, it literally
became a joke at some point,
that every like, cause every year
you would do a school thing.
- [Gigguk] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I remember I
would do the 400 meters,
and I would not stop
sprinting the whole time,
and I would let you get to the,
I would sprint the
whole 400 meters to win,
I would stop, and I would
just go(burp sound).
(laughter) Cause I was pushing myself
way beyond what was
needed cause in my head,
it was embarrassing to lose.
- I mean, I get people like that but..
- And before anyone
thinks, wow, man, Connor
your parents must have raised you in a way
that made you fit,
but no, my parents were like,
yo Connor, calm the fuck down.
Like my parents were like,
where did this come from?
Cause we are not like that.
- I guess that's interesting
you say that though,
because then now I'm wondering
why you're so heavily into Arc knights.
Because Arc Knights is a
PVE game, not a PVP game.
- Wow.
- But it's still got, I think I know.
Cause it's still got
like challenges in there,
and Arc Knights is the worst
fucking like combo for you,
cause it's a game that you can't win,
unless you spend more money.
And then even if you spend more
money, you still can't win.
- And there's a whole bit of enjoyment,
by following the story.
- I didn't follow the story.
You know, I've, you know,
I've level 95 on Arc Knights,
but now that I've beaten
all of episode six,
and done all the challenge modes,
I kind of woke up the
other day and I'm like,
what have I got to do?(laughter)
I've done it, I've done everything.
- I've done it.
- I'm in the end game.
I've completed the Arc.
But like that's the thing, right?
And then I think I also
destroyed any chance I had
of liking story games cause
when achievements were a
thing on X-Box three 60
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- You bet I was that asshole.
(crosstalk)
- Yeah.
- And I got way too into some games,
and I remember I got so
frustrated with JLPGs,
cause I would just buy any game.
But there was due to research
which games were easiest
to get achievements on.
I didn't do that.
I just bought a game
and I would complete it.
But fuck JLPGs, man.
They had the worst achievements.
They were like collect
every one of this item.
And then you would go to the guide,
and it'd be like, Oh,
well, seven of these items
you can only get at that time.
And if you didn't get it
at that time, sorry kid
you gotta restart the game.
And I'm like, I hate you.
Who did this?
I hate you so so much.
- I think that was a saving
grace for me that I never owned
like an X-Box three 60 or a PlayStation.
Like I never played on a
console that had achievements.
I was always just the Nintendo kid.
So it was literally just
you versus the game.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- I wish I did that because I
remember I got an X-Box one,
and one day I was like, why am I,
why am I getting these achievements?
Like, what am I, what am I?
- I thought like he had the
feeling, like(indistinct)
I can perfect the skill to
get all of the achievements.
Oh, okay, it's on, it's challenging me.
This is a challenge.
- And I looked back at all the shit I did,
like I beat the Lost video game,
the fucking Lost video game.
And I remember that even..
- I didn't even know, there
was a Lost video game.
- Even my 15-year old self could tell
this video game was not a video game.
Like this was garbage dude.
And I beat it just to
get that 1000 and she,
I hated that game.
- Yeah, actually question to you then,
do you kind of like gamify life sometimes?
Like do you?
- You know what's weird?
Okay, that's a good question.
- Yeah.
- Do you wanna explain
what you're going to go
with the rest(indistinct)
- No, because like basically,
you know, sometimes,
I do see our job YouTube,
as it's kind of like a game right?
Cause, they fucking gamified this.
You get achievements, you get numbers,
you got your rivals, you
know, you do a good video,
it gives you a Pat on the back.
It gives you like a, like a
green tick mark to be like,
you did well, you did well
- It's weird, right?
Because I saw, I read about this
and it's called a maximizer
and a satisfier, right?
Some people will take the first
option that satisfies them.
- [Gigguk] Yeah.
- And they're okay with that.
There are other people
who maximize the shit
out of everything.
- Yeah.
- And I do know what happened,
but somewhere around the age of 18 to 20,
I swapped from being a maximizer
and literally everything in my life.
- Yeah.
- To just being satisfied.
And like I remember when
I was buying a vacuum
for the first time.
Holy shit, dude, I like
spreadsheets on spreadsheets.
I was like, yo, put the
suction power of this one,
is 50 Watts, extra and
shit, this is bristles,
extra firm ones there.
But the reviews of this one, Oh my!
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like I would get stressed
out about everything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That happened with YouTube and stuff.
But somewhere along the line
I just stopped giving a
shit about everything.
- Yeah.
- And I'm like now, you know, even when I,
I remember I used to book hotels,
I used to like, Oh my God,
I would search every hotel
in like a 10 mile radius.
I would have a spreadsheet.
And I just got to the
point where I realized,
I don't think this matters,
I don't think I need to do this.
- Yeah.
- And now I just take the first thing
that makes me remotely happy.
- Yeah I mean, it's just kind of like,
decision fatigue right?
Like there's only so many decisions
that you can make in a day.
- [Connor] Yeah.
And there are some points
when I'm exactly the same,
especially when I'm
like booking a holiday,
or finding like even just like choosing
what you wanna eat today.
- Yeah, I'd say the only thing
I still do it in my life,
is for video games.
Like I still do that for video games,
but everything else, even
YouTube, I just do what I do,
and I'm satisfied with that.
Like I, I checked the analytics,
I, you know, like roughly,
but I don't go deep into them.
Like I just see like, okay.
- You are not like Oh my God,
I'm down 1% from yesterday?
- If I gain less subscribers
than the previous day,
I don't care, I'm like, I'm
still gaining subscribers.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I actually found out like a
huge problem for me recently
is that ,I found it really
hard just to get into new anime
and games just because like
there's so much choice.
And I don't know,
I have this thing where I'm
so scared of wasting my time.
- See that's the thing you need to let go.
Like I had that, I had that,
and I just stopped giving it a shit.
- Cause like recently, okay,
so the most recent anime I've finished,
was one that he had last season,
it was called a Sing Yesterday For Me.
And like the first beginning
of that was fucking great.
I was like, I'm good.
This is gonna be a show.
This is like anime of the
season kind of territory.
And then I watched it and
the first half was great.
And then the second half
was just kind of like,
nothing's really happening,
and then it ended
and then it just kind
of just ended very fast.
It was obviously like
a very rushed ending.
It was like the most seven out 10 overall.
You know what I mean?
- I remember your tweet
where you were like guys,
watching yesterday anime of
the season, take it from me.
The anime song.
- Like yes, you have that story.
- And, like, I like, I just
I remember I finished it
and I knew this was an anime
I'm going to forget in like a month.
- That's okay.
- Is it though?
- I think its okay, Cause
the way I see things, right?
is like no matter what happens,
if I got something I can
talk about, that's a win.
Like you pulled it up, right?
- Yeah.
- It's all about the experience.
- Yeah, you had something you..
- It was the friends we made
along the way.(laughter)
- We are (indistinct)
- At the end of the day,
we're all knocking my baby.
- If I have something
that I can take away,
like that, it's painfully mediocre,
that's something I can talk about.
I can't be mad at that.
- But imagine I didn't have a podcast,
where I could just talk about it.
- You can talk about it to your friends.
- You can talk about it
to your friends, right?
You could have said this.
- Okay, if it had been good,
would you have been happy?
- Yes.
- No, you wouldn't have,
you'd have been like,
satisfied with the choice you made.
You wouldn't have been happy.
- No, I would like, because.
- What do you mean?
He would have.
- No, no.
- He just watched a good anime.
- Cause he wanted it
to be an amazing anime.
And if it lived up to his
expectations, he'd be like, good.
He wouldn't be like, Oh my God, yes!
- Well, I mean like, I mean.
- I know this guy.
- No, no I would be happy.
- Fuck off.
- Fuck you, I would be happy.
I'm happy watching good anime.
- No, no.
- Don't show me like, okay.
Like, okay the one thing that's even worse
than being a bad anime is
just being a meh anime.
Like I remember like When I
finished domestic girlfriend,
like the Manga.
Okay, so I finished it
like a few weeks ago.
- We go back to this again.
- We are going back to domestic girlfriend
- He always finds a way
to bring it back up.
He always finds a fucking way.
- It's like that ex-girlfriend,
that he just can't let go.
- I can't let her go but
it was an awful ending.
Like it was, it was absolutely like one of
one of the worst endings
to like a horror Manga.
- This is the worst trade deal.
- You are not selling us on this one.
- Okay, just imagine it, right.
This is what it was like, okay, imagine.
Okay, it's the world cup final, okay?
- [Connor] All right.
- [Joey] Okay.
- Okay, in terms of like,
which girl was gonna win.
- Okay, okay.
- All right.
- So it's the world cup final
you're in the 90th minute.
It's Instapage time.
You're like ten one up, okay.
And then for no, like the other team,
is like completely incapacitated.
And then for no reason you
decided to play golden goal
and then score an own goal.
That was the ending of
domestic girlfriend.
- Well, that's that's fun,
you can talk about that.
- No, no, no, no.
But that, but that's the thing right?
Is that because it was so
bad, I had a great time,
like experiencing just the dumpster fire.
Unlike the nuclear fallout(indistinct)
- It was fun, right?
- Yeah, like I had more fun with,
I'm gonna remember domestic
girlfriend for way way longer.
Than sing yesterday for me.
Because what I'm so scared of is just,
I'm gonna watch a show
and I'm gonna be like,
and I'm gonna forget the
show, within a month.
- But that happens a lot.
- It does, it does.
- Well, if you'd like,
as somebody who watches
so many fucking documentaries,
like I watch a lot of documentaries.
It's probably the only thing
I really watch on Netflix.
- Right.
- Kind of come to accept that real life,
doesn't have good endings.(laughter)
Unfortunately like life just doesn't have.
- It just kind of ends.
- It just doesn't have
good endings, right?
Like, you know, if you make documentaries
about people who are still alive,
sometimes they keep doing shit
after the documentary comes out,
then it's like, it's not
a complete documentary,
but I don't know.
I just kind of get like
satisfied with what I get,
if it's a good journey.
And if it's a mad ending,
that's something I could talk about.
That's the way I see it.
Like if (indistinct) documentary, great,
I have something to talk about.
It's a good documentary,
cool, I can talk about it.
Like I've just come to accept
that life just doesn't have good endings.
(crosstalk)
- Put that on a T-shirt.
- Yeah.
- You know, like, come on, tiger King,
first part was way better
than the last part.
I, mean come on man.
- Yeah, of course.
- You know what I mean?
Like it's I dunno.
I just come to accept that
it was good when it was good,
and I'm not gonna get too fussed about it.
- That's the whole thing, right?
It's just, it's just this idea of like,
you know, nothing in life is pointless.
Like you'll always find a way
to utilize that in some way.
And no matter how fucking
mediocre a show is,
you're gonna use it somewhere,
even if you're not even aware
of it, right like, yeah.
- I realize how fucking
weird I am right now,
cause I just don't like
story in video games,
but I'm happy with mediocre
stories(indistinct)
(laughter)
- Then you love a lot of visual moments.
- Oh my God.
I mean, I don't know, it's hard.
This is like a debate that
I'm trying to come to terms
with myself as like, is it okay
to watch something mediocre?
- But is it okay to play
something for the story?
- Yeah, exactly.
- No, never, everyone's like,
did you play last of us?
No, cause it's all story.
- But you get to shoot things in it.
- No, there's no skill involved.
- There's nothing I can master.
- I loved Halo, and I
loved playing the like,
legendary roots alone where like
it's fucking impossible to
shoot driving up the wall.
- It's not like every 12 year old,
I didn't talk to in school.(laughter)
- I think we wouldn't get on in school.
- If we went to the same school,
I would be like, fuck that guy.(laughing)
who plays Halo, Legendary,
man, what a wanker!
- Man, I love that shit, its a good game.
- Jesus Christ.
- No, but so yeah.
Is there, is there anything
else you guys wanna talk about
on this podcast?
- Bottom line,
I don't think Connor is ever gonna get
into visual novels and
that's just how it is.
- Like, the more I talk to him,
the more I'm like, yeah, visual novel..
- It's the Neto of animating
my mind, It's like you..
- It's a refined taste.
- It's not even a refined taste.
- It's like, I feel like
you are either genetically
I suppose what's the
word like you're going to
you're more likely to like it,
what's the word?
There's a word for, I don't fucking know.
Supposed or something, it's
something along those lines.
It's not that word.
- Yeah, we're a bit drunk, right?
- I feel like you're
either going to like visual
novels or you're not.
And you know, cause if someone explained
a visual novel to you
you're going to be like, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know, but like
I've never met someone ,
who just doesn't like story period.
Yeah, that's like, if you don't like story
in games, period, then I'm like.
- I like story, not in video games.
Get out of my video games, raw force
amazing game metal slug, amazing game.
No stories in those games.
That's what we need.
- You are telling me,
you never looked up the wall
of metal slug?(laughter)
- I have played too many
hours in metal slug,
loved that game to death.
I have no idea if there is a story.
Is there a story in metal slug?
- Apparently there is.
- Is there?
Fuck off, no there isn't.
- Yeah, there's apparently a story.
- The new doom, I fucking loved,
but I was like, wait,
wait there's cut scenes.
No, no, no, no.
- But you're not like,
care about something like
world building, for example.
- Yeah, but you can do
that through gameplay.
- Yeah, but it's not as effective.
There's so many, okay
there's so many games
that try to do world
building through game play.
- Right, you play the new dooms,
you know exactly what the
world is about, just from.
- But aren't you like actually
interested in the world?
- No.(laughter)
- And there's your short answer, really?
(crosstalk)
- I say that, right, but
every time I hear a piece
of like legal legends law,
I'm like, Oh, that's cool.
That's cool.
And I actually, I'd watch
a league of legends anime.
- Yeah.
- But I don't wanna
watch league of legends
cut scenes in game.
Imagine you have to watch cut scenes
in league of legends, you'd be like.
- Connor has like two modes in his brain.
And there's like, no in-between.
It's just like shut off
brain, like absorb anime.
It could be shit, you're
just like absorb it.
Or it's like monkey brain mode engage.
- I am the greatest primate in this group.
- It's like on or off, right.
Like I can sit there and
watch light any anime
or whatever you need me to watch.
I could sit there and watch
it all day and be like, okay
I know what I'm getting into.
But when it's games, get
that shit out of here.
Get that shit off of me.(laughter)
- Jesus Christ.
- I literally like, I
love watching Tyler Wan,
like live streams cause
I feel like he embodies.
- He's the definition of monkey brains.
- I love Tyler Wan as a streamer,
because he literally embodies like,
not only physically how I
imagined my game of size to be,
but like watching him play
The Last Of Us was so funny,
cause he was just like,
what is this story?
Get this shit away from me.
And I was like, I love it,
I love it, it's so fun.
He's just such a like
giga-chatted, brain gamer.
It's so fun to watch him.
He's my favorite streamer.
Just cause I relate to
that on so many levels.
- Oh my God, I guess
you guys can let us know
in the comments below,
if there is any visual
novel that you think
Connor's monkey brain can handle.
- I've lost all hope that Connor
can get into visual novels.
- We can't, we can't convince him,
so maybe you guys can help us.
- Yeah, yeah, okay, you know
what, before we finish this.
People were like, yeah,
I've beat Fire Emblem.
I was like, Oh yeah, me too.
And they were like, Oh, did
you play with the roots?
I'm like, why would I play
with the roots?(laughter)
- I remember talking to you about this.
- That hurts me.
- I'm like, why would
I play with the roots?
- You play blue lions right?
- I play blue lions, which I, you know
after I heard about all the other routes,
I'm like so I played the right one.
- No, no.
There's no right one.
- Yeah.
- That's just one of three.
- And mine sounded like the most.
- So we were going back
into Fate now.(laughing)
- No, no, we're not doing this.
We were close to ending the episode.
All I'm saying is that,
to me the point of playing
the same gameplay again
for a different ending is,
it doesn't make any sense to me.
It's like, the thought of that is insane.
- We'll never be able to
understand this monkey brain.
- No, no.
- Science please dissect my brain.
- I need to do like a full on
study to be like, okay story.
You like story.
Connor is like, yes, yes.
I like story.
- I like story.
- Gameplay, gameplay you like gameplay.
- No, no, no.
- Yes I like game play.
Story and gameplay, no, no.
Story and game play bad.
I do know like.
- Basically that's pretty accurate.
- Jesus Christ.
- I think that's why I love arcades.
Cause like they don't
try and give you story.
It's great.
They don't try and bulk
me down with this shit.
- Apparently the nostalgia,
the piano game has a law.
- I can't read Japanese
so I wouldn't know anyway.
You know what game is amazing
with fantastic game play
and no story?
- What?
- Chess.
No story in chess.
That's why I like chess so much I think.
it started from a young age,
my displeased(indistinct).
- It's actually funny,
cause the thing I like
about chess is the story
and law behind the history
of chess.(laughing)
- There are two people in the world,
two different people
in the world right now.
- But saying that, right?
If you made a documentary
about chess players,
I'd fucking love the shit out
of that cause I don't have to,
It's not like, it's not like..
- Because it's not
interjected with gameplay.
- Because yeah, because
It's not like 10 minutes in,
move the pawn forward two.
It's like, okay, it's not like,
cause some of these visual
novels have game play
and I've seen some of the shit,
and it's like, you click
one dialogue like thing.
And it's like, why give me the
choice to click one dialogue?
- Yeah, except that one piece of gameplay,
is the most stressful
piece of gameplay ever,
because it's like, Oh my God
which one do I shoot?
- [Gigguk] Exactly, right?
- Chess the documentary, I would watch.
Chess the game, I play.
Chess, the visual novel
slash documentary game,
no, get that outta here.
I don't wanna know.
- You are like the epitome of
someone who can't multitask.
- I actually can't multitask whatsoever.
I say that.
- It shows.
- Yeah, maybe I watch anime in the gym,
that's about as far as it goes.
- Wow.
- Keigo brain, keigo brain.
- What an evolved brain, you have.
- Me crying on the treadmill.(indistinct)
- I think that's a good place
to end this podcast before,
like we're gonna need a whole like study,
on how Connor's brain works.
- Yeah.
- Why is my brain so smooth?
- You know people are gonna
meme the fuck out of this
on the (indistinct)
- That's fine.
- Please give us your meme.
Your best like Connor
is monkey brain memes.
- Checkout our sub reddits
and our Twitter, If you like,
also thank you very much
to all our Patreons.
- Hell yeah.
- They are on our screen right now.
- Those guys, they no listen to story.
They just won the gameplay.
If you'd like to support us on the show,
and also fund the research
to try and figure out
Connor's monkey brain, the
patreon is gonna help us a lot.
So make sure if you enjoy the show
to go on to Patreon.com/TrashTaste.
- (indistinct) great
game, no game, no story.
- I kind of want to get Tyler
one on this podcast now.
(crosstalk)
- Tyler Wan please come on the podcast,
and talk about anime and
monkey stuff with us.
- Oh, that would be awesome, definitely.
- And also thank you to our sponsor
for this episode as well.
But yeah, I think that's
a good place to end it.
So with that said I've
been Gigguk and joining me
today has been monkey brain.
- Oh shit, that's gonna be my nickname.
- We got Tyler two here.
- Tyler two.(laughing)
- We've got the anime
man, Joey, and I'm Gigguk
and I guess we'll see you all next time.
Bye.
- Bye
- Johnny.
- Get this shit off of me.
(bright upbeat music)